Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast der ESA und des DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur zehnten Ausgabe dieser Serie von Gesprächen über Raumfahrtechnik und mehr. Und ja, für die zehnte Ausgabe haben wir wieder ein sehr schönes Thema, wie ich finde, was auch ja viel Geschichte hat, aber auch sehr aktuell ist immer noch. Und zwar möchten wir hier reden über Raumstationen. Und dazu begrüße ich Reinhold, Reinhold Ewald, hallo.
Hallo Tim, hallo liebe Hörer.
Ja, du bist, also wir müssen sagen, wo wir sind. Wir sind in Oberpfaffenhofen, diesmal nicht beim DLR, sondern bei der ESA. Auch die ESA hat natürlich hier ihre eigene Präsenz. Und ja, bei der ESA bist du ja auch im Wesentlichen aktiv.
Genau, als ESA-Astronaut hatte ich Gelegenheit das Wachsen und Gedeihen der Internationalen Raumstation aktiv zu begleiten, vom Boden aus. Viele meiner ESA-Kollegen sind im Zeitraum ab etwa 2000 zur Internationalen Raumstation geflogen, haben da länger oder kürzer arbeiten können. Und das Ganze fließt jetzt ein in das, was wir täglich hier tun, nämlich den Betrieb unseres Columbus-Laboratoriums. Das ist das Laboratorium, das die ESA zur Raumstation geschickt hat, seit Februar 2008. Also jetzt seit drei Jahren betreiben wir das Columbus-Laboratorium und sind in Verbindung dort mit Houston, mit Moskau, mit den anderen Kontrollzentren, die die Internationalen Raumstation am Leben erhalten.
Und das Steuerungszentrum von Columbus ist hier in Oberpfaffenhofen?
Genau, 24 Stunden, sieben Tage die Woche. Da sitzt ein Team im Kontrollraum 4, wie wir den nennen, ganz unpathetisch und schaut sich die Daten an, die von Columbus empfangen werden, nimmt die nötigen Korrekturen vor, beobachtet natürlich auch die Crews, die Mitglieder der Besatzung, die in Columbus arbeiten, gibt Hinweise, Tipps für die Nutzlasten, für die Systeme. Alles das, was eigentlich entlastend für die Astronauten oben automatisch gemacht werden kann, das machen wir.
Ja, das ist hier die Situation vor Ort. Bevor wir aber die aktuelle Situation noch ein bisschen genauer und tiefer beleuchten, würde ich erst mal gerne ein wenig zurückgehen in die Geschichte. Vielleicht auch erst mal in deine persönliche Geschichte. Wie fing das so bei dir an, so mit dem Weltall und der Verbindung?
Mit Schule, obwohl die Schule deutete jetzt noch nicht auf irgendwas technisches Sinn. Ich war bei einem altsprachlichen Gymnasium, humanistisch-altsprachlichen Gymnasium, allerdings damals natürlich schon mit naturwissenschaftlichen Zweig, sodass ich also die Physik entdeckte und das auch studiert habe. Ich habe Experimentalphysik an der Universität Köln studiert, habe mich um das Thema Radioastronomie bemüht, also auch schon den Kopf gehoben und in den Himmel geschaut, wenn auch mit großen Antennen. Und das Ganze führte dann dazu, dass ich nach meinem Studium auch die Möglichkeit beworben habe, Astronaut zu werden.
Von welchem Zeitraum reden wir jetzt?
Wir reden von 1986 etwa, hatte die Promotion gerade abgeschlossen. Da ist man ja offen für Neues. Diese Anzeige, wir suchen Nachwuchs für unser Astronautenteam, unser deutsches Astronautenteam damals, warum nicht? Ich meine, da wirft man dann sein Zettel in den Lostopf und guckt mal, wie weit man kommt. Ich bin relativ weit gekommen bis in die Schlussrunde. 13 Kandidaten wurden da interviewt, von denen fünf genommen wurden. Ich war damals nicht dabei, das hat mich aber nicht weiter frustriert. Die Auswahl allein war schon ein Erlebnis. Aber 1990 ist danach berufen worden. Man brauchte mehr Astronauten, auch um die neuen russischen Missionen mit bedienen zu können, die durch die Öffnung des Eisernen Vorhangs für uns möglich geworden waren. Und dann war ich dabei.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein relativ... Ohne viel Hindernisse direkt in die Kapsel. Ist ja ein bisschen ungewöhnlich, oder?
Ja, doch. Also ich meine, direkt in die Kapsel, in dem Moment, wo man sich bewirbt, ist man noch ein paar Jahre weg von der Kapsel. So war das auch bei mir. Ich habe 1990 bis 92 mein erstes Training im legendären Sternstädtchen näher von Moskau im Hinblick auf einen Flug zur Raumstation Mir, also zu der damaligen russischen Raumstation, absolviert, zusammen mit einem sehr netten Kollegen, Klaus-Sidrich Vlade. Und dann ging es am Ende drum, wer fliegt jetzt? Es war nur ein Ticket da und ich habe dann Klaus während seines Fluges vom Boden aus unterstützt, also wieder ein Kontrollzentrum gesehen, von innen gesehen, auch im Kontrollzentrum gearbeitet, nämlich das in Moskau, bevor es dann nach einer Zeit vertraglich zu einer zweiten Mission kam. Und da war ich dann wieder dabei, diesmal mit Hans Schlegel, der inzwischen seinen Flug auf dem Spacelab D2 absolviert hatte, der dann mit mir wiederum durch ein Training lief und diesmal fiel die Wahl dann auf mich.
Wenn man noch mal ein bisschen weiter zurückblättert, was hast du gesagt, Radioastronomie, das hat mich gleich beschäftigt. In welchem Alter hat denn das überhaupt eingesetzt, diese Faszination?
Die Faszination ist schon sehr lange da. Ich bin wirklich als Junge mit der Mondlandung und bin first in Space, also die Ersttaten im Weltraum aufgewachsen. Das hat mich schon sehr früh interessiert und fasziniert auch, so dass ich auch Science-Fiction in der Stadtbibliothek in Mönchengladbach, wo ich herkomme, praktisch die ganze Science-Fiction-Literatur leergelesen habe. Aber ohne jetzt konkret darauf hin zu studieren, ich möchte mal Astronaut werden, die Beschäftigung mit der Physik war eher wirklich von Interesse getragen, also von allgemeinem Interesse. Die großen Fragen, wo kommen wir her, wo gehen wir hin, Leben im All, Entstehung der Sterne, das sind Sachen natürlich, die von der Physik her am besten anzugehen sind.
Gehörten da auch Filme dazu?
Filme gehörten natürlich dazu, 2001 prägend. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit Commander Alistair McLean als Kommandant der Orion da auch einen entscheidenden Anstoß gegeben hat. In der Rolle habe ich mich eigentlich nie gesehen. Also ich mit kühlem Kopf eine Besatzung kommandieren, das war eine andere Kiste. Ich wollte eher die Möglichkeiten des Weltraums nutzen.
Bleiben wir noch kurz bei 2001. Sicherlich einer der besten, wenn nicht vielleicht sogar der beste Film, der überhaupt jemals gedreht wurde. Vor allem auch erschreckend in seinem Realismus, der stille Weltraum, der sonst immer mit Explosionen durchjagt ist. Wenn man sich so Science-Fictions anschaut, da geht es ja immer ganz wild zu. Aber da dominierte ja die stille bzw. an der blauen Donau begleitet einen auf einem ersten Flug, nachdem die Menschheit sozusagen aufgebrochen ist, zu einer Raumstation, die sich da so im Orbit oder wo auch immer herumdreht. Ist die Raumstation eigentlich so der Inbegriff des Raumfahrtraums?
Es ist sicherlich nicht der Endpunkt des Raumfahrtraums. Das merken wir zur Zeit, wo über die Zukunft nach der Raumstation diskutieren. Ich will das nicht unterschätzen. Eine Raumstation im nahen Erdorbit zu verankern, zu betreiben, auch auf die Idee zu kommen, wie man die vergrößern kann, wie man die ganze Versorgungslage da in den Griff bekommt. Das hat ja auch in Stufen erst Gestalt angenommen. Das ist eine Riesenleistung. Da muss man erst mal sagen, Mission accomplished. Also wir haben es geschafft, die Europäer waren Gott sei Dank dabei, in einem sehr internationalen Projekt, ich will nicht sagen größten und friedfertigsten und faszinierendsten Projekt der nach kalte Kriegzeit. Aber das ist schon alles das, wofür die ISS steht. Wir haben es geschafft, diese Raumstation dort oben in Betrieb zu nehmen und auch zur Zeit sinnvoll zu nutzen und auch mit Zukunftsperspektive auszustatten, trotz aller Ingenieurschwierigkeiten, die das bedeutet. Und das ist ein Riesenschritt, aber ist sicherlich nicht der letzte Schritt hinaus ins Weltall. Denn da kann auch eine Raumstation nicht mit der Faszination der Mondlandung oder mit dem, was von einer zukünftigen Mars-Landung ausgeht, konkurrieren. Schön, dass wir über diese Möglichkeit heute, über dieses Gespräch auch die Chance haben, diese Leistung Raumstationen mal gebührend zu würdigen. Die ja nun mit sehr vielen Vorversuchen auch erst zustande kamen. Über die wir sicherlich dann noch reden oder ähnliche Vorläufer.
Ja, gehen wir noch mal da in die Vergangenheit rein. Also die Raumstation ist vor allem ja eine, nicht ausschließlich, aber vor allem durch die russische Seite extrem geprägte Geschichte. Wenn ich es richtig sehe, waren die Russen überhaupt die Ersten, die so die Idee einer permanenten Basis im Orbit überhaupt vorangetrieben haben.
Die Idee war ja schon da und die Durchführung im Film, die sieht sich natürlich ganz anders an als das, was wir dann angetroffen haben. Die Idee war da mit Tsiolkovsky, die Idee war da auch in der amerikanischen Literatur. Obert hat sich ja auch in die praktischen Belange einer solchen Raumstation schon reinbewegt. Das waren aber alles große Gebilde, die im Inneren ausgestattet waren, wie ein Mittelklasse-Hotel oder wie eine Flughafen-Lounge mit Leder-Sesseln und künstlicher Gravitation. Künstliche Gravitation gibt es nicht, also durch Rotation ersetzte man dann die Gravitation durch eine Zertifugalkraft. Alles das sind Dinge, die sich in unserer heutigen Raumstation nicht wiederfinden und mit gutem Grund nicht wiederfinden, weil wir eben eher dem Design oder künstlerischen Übertreibungsfantasien entspringen als der technischen Realität. Man muss auf jedem einzelnen Gebiet ja erstmal arbeiten, um eine Raumstation betreiben zu können. Man muss die Konstruktion im Griff bekommen, den Transport ins All in den Griff bekommen und wenn man sie dann betreibt, auch die Dinge, die auf der Erde selbstverständlich sind, dort oben durch Mechanik, durch Elektrik, durch ähnliche Geräte dann ersetzen. Und das ist das Interessante, das ist das Faszinierende, was wir mit dieser Raumstation eigentlich auch lernen können.
Die Russen haben angefangen, eine Serie von Raumstationsexperimenten oder Raumstationen zu starten und haben das ja auch geschafft. Nicht bei allen. Die Soyuz-Serie. Sagt man. Ich bin es Russischen nicht mächtig, muss ich zugeben.
Nein, Soyuz, ist der Gruß, war also eine militärische Entwicklung. Eigentlich noch davor, ich bin jetzt kein Experte in russischer Raumfahrthistorie, aber da gab es sowas wie Almaz, das sind so Edelsteinnamen, die dienten dazu, Dreck und kleine Steine auf den Gegner zu werfen aus dem All. Der Sputnik-Schock hat ja auch damit zu tun, dass man jetzt fürchtet, dass aus dem All böse Sachen dann auf den jeweiligen Kontinent abgeworfen worden, der feindlich gesinnt ist oder sowas. Das ist natürlich Unsinn. Ich glaube auch, die Militärs haben relativ schnell erkannt, dass das Potenzial einer Raumstation für die Zwecke der Aufklärung oder auch der Bedrohung relativ ungeeignet ist. So dass zu der Zeit, wo ich dann auch schon in die Mirre einstieg, eigentlich die militärische Nutzung schon sich abgewandt hatte und andere Satelliten und Aufklärungssystem im All hatte, als dass man die Raumstation dann noch nutzen muss. Ein Glücksfall eigentlich für die zivile Nutzung der Raumstation. Also diese Kette von Versuchen, sich im All länger als nur mit einem Flug einer einzelnen Kapsel zu verankern, das ist tatsächlich der Gründungszeitpunkt der Idee der Raumstation.
Das heißt, die ersten Missionen der Russen hatten jetzt nicht unbedingt eine permanente Besatzung, sondern es ging eigentlich eher darum, schon mal etwas oben zu haben und dann immer wieder hinfliegen zu können, sich eine Weile dort aufzuhalten und dann, wenn die Mission beendet ist, kehren alle wieder zurück.
Genau so. Das heißt, man hatte einen Dockingverbinder, an den eine Kapsel andocken konnte. Die verbrauchten dann die Kekse und das Wasser, was sie mit hatten und dann mussten sie wieder runter, weil eben kein Nachschub zu bekommen war. In einer zweiten Generation hat man dieses Nachschubproblem gelöst, in dem dann noch ein Koppelungsknoten vorgesehen wurde, in dem dann unbemannte Transportraumschiffe zum Beispiel einflogen oder Zusatzmodule, die entsprechende Vorräte enthielten. Und dann war es dann schon besser mit der Versorgung der Besatzung. Dann konnten also auch mehrere Besatzungen nacheinander diese Raumstation nutzen, ohne dass sie ihr eigenes Material mitbringen konnte. Auf der anderen Seite wurde damit auch der Transport von Nutzlasten plus Besatzung sehr stark zurückgeschnitten. Also man konnte Nutzlast und Besatzung trennen. Das ist ein entscheidender Schritt, den die Amerikaner nicht gegangen sind, weil sie sich mit der Entwicklung des Shuttle darauf dann kapriziert haben, dass Besatzung und Zweck der Mission gemeinsam ins All gehen. Transport von Satelliten, das Space Lab als Laboratorium im Packraum des Shuttle, das waren Missionen, die dann aber auch von der Dauer entsprechend begrenzt waren. Zehn, 14 Tage, das war das Maximum. Die Russen haben das entkoppelt und konnten dadurch die Missionsdauer immer weiter steigern.
Das ist also auch eine ganz andere Herangehensweise. Warum? Also es ist ein bisschen verwunderlich. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite viele Ideen und Wünsche waren ja parallel da. Man will zum Mond, man will einfach überhaupt erst mal ein Satelliten starten. Nur bei den Raumstationen ging es irgendwie auseinander, habe ich so den Eindruck, dass einfach die Russen eine ganz andere Strategie verfolgt haben als die Amerikaner.
Richtig.
Woran lag das?
Das war wohl die industriepolitische Seite, die in Russland ja mehr Staatsobjekte ist, also Staatsziele verfolgte als in den USA. In den USA war die Präsenz im All wichtig, aber nach den großen Wegwerfraketen der Apollo-Zeit eben auch die Idee, die Industrie anzuspornen, wiederverwendbare Systeme zu entwickeln. Auch woraus dann der Shuttle entstand. Dass sich der Shuttle nicht als so wiederverwendbar und so billig einsetzbar erwies, wie das in den ursprünglichen Planungen der Fall war, das ist die Tragik eigentlich dieses Shuttle-Systems. Dass es mit so vielen Aufgaben billaden und überladen wurde, dass im Laufe der Zeit erhebliche Defizite trotz der Wiederverwendbarkeit dann zutage kamen. Der enorme Aufwand, einen Shuttle für den Start auszurüsten, die Kosten pro Mission, das sind alles Dinge, die erst in der Laufzeit des Shuttle dann zutage kamen und eigentlich den ursprünglichen Plan widersprachen. Die Russen sind bei billig geblieben. Die entsprechende Versorgungsrakete, Soyuz, ist inzwischen einer der bewährtesten Typen bei mancher Rakete. Und relativ billig dann auch auf die Startrampe zu bringen, auf wenig Aufwand zu starten.
Das heißt, aus ökonomischen Gesichtspunkten ist die Strategie der Russen sehr gut aufgegangen?
Aus ökonomischen Gesichtspunkten, ja. Allerdings muss man sagen, ohne den Shuttle, also das Space Transportation System, um genau zu sein, hätten wir die Raumstation nicht, weil natürlich dann die Fähigkeit, Dinge an Bord, auch in großer Menge an Bord zu bringen, sehr beschränkt gewesen wäre, durch nur vermehrte Flüge der kleineren russischen Flotte dann auszugleichen gewesen wären.
Dieses Docking-Prinzip ist ja eigentlich die Schlüsseltechnologie bei der Raumstation. Um überhaupt erst mal im Orbit zwei Raumfahrzeuge miteinander zu verbinden, das war ja denke ich mal so die primäre Ingenieursleistung dabei. Also ansonsten gleicht das Ding ja zunächst erst mal einem Satelliten. Wie schwierig ist Docking?
So, dass man relativ früh auch schon in den Mondprogrammen, also wir gehen zurück auf Gemini und entsprechende Versuche auch der Russen mit den Vostok kapseln, dass man also diese Versuche relativ zügig in Angriff genommen hat. Und das wird auch heute noch bestätigt, dadurch dass die Chinesen, die ja auch jetzt nachfolgen auf dem Weg in die bemannte Raumfahrt, dass die Chinesen auch als nächstes Ziel angeben, Orbitalteile miteinander zu verbinden. Teile, die im Orbit dann schon vorher verbracht wurden, mit der bemannten Kapsel dann auch zu verbinden und um diese Docking, also um das Ankoppeln nachzuweisen. Das Ankoppeln, dem voraus geht ja das Navigieren, also das Anfliegen von entsprechenden Zielen, die Nahfeld-Navigation, das Einregeln von Geschwindigkeit, Lage, so dass man diese Verbindung auch schafft. Das sind ja alles, was die Avionik angeht und die Orientierungsfähigkeit, herausragende Errungenschaften in den 60er Jahren gewesen, die heute natürlich mit satellitengestützten Systemen und Laser und optischer Kommunikation sehr viel entwickelter sind. Wir sehen das jetzt gerade im Falle des ATV, des unbemachten Transporters, den die ESA zur Internationalen Raumstation schickt, mit wie viel modernsten System dieses Kapsel ausgerüstet ist, um sich an die Raumstation automatisch heranzu navigieren und gefahrlos anzuköpeln. Das ist eine Riesenentwicklung, das Navigieren und auch das mechanisch miteinander verbinden. Die Russen haben zwei Typen von Adaptern entwickelt. Einen, den sie auch heute noch für ihre Docking-Manöver im russischen Teil der Raumstation verwenden. Und das andere ist einer, der dann international genutzt wurde, also der auch die Verbindung damals zur Apollo-Soyuz-Mission herstellte und der heute auch noch in ungearbeiteter Form an einer Raumstation existent ist.
Ja, die internationale Schnittstelle sozusagen.
Die internationale Schnittstelle. Also koppeln, annähern, koppeln und dann auch den mechanischen Verbund stabilisieren. Das sind diese Aufgaben, die mit erst gelöst werden müssen, bevor man an einer Raumstation denken kann.
Und vielleicht noch mal beim Docking zu bleiben. Also was macht es eigentlich so schwierig? Also was ist die eigentliche Herausforderung? Und wie geht dieser Docking-Prozess vonstatten? Vor allem erstmal so ein Blick auf die ersten einfache Systeme, wobei ich jetzt so die Vermutung habe, dass sich so viel daran gar nicht geändert hat.
Tatsächlich gibt es im Russischen eine Tradition, bewährtes auch beizubehalten. Und so sehen wir also viele der Ideen, die damals auch schon entwickelt wurden in der Wostockzeit, aber auch dann bei Soyuz-Mir, die sehen wir heute auch noch in gleicher Form ablaufen. Die Elektronik ist natürlich ein bisschen weniger voluminös geworden, hat an Leistungsfähigkeit gewonnen. Und man führt auch neue Systeme ein, radartechnisch oder dann auch Positionierungssysteme. Aber im Wesentlichen ist der Ablauf immer derselbe. Man muss unterscheiden zwischen dem Ankoppeln eines relativ leichten, also massenarmen Fahrzeugs in der 10-Tonnen-Klasse mit einer Raumstation, die vielleicht 200, 300 Tonnen Masse schon aufweist. Da ist natürlich klar, dass dann das Raumfahrzeug das agilere Element in dieser Kopplungskoreografie ist. Die Raumstation nimmt dann einen Inertialflugweg ein, wird also ihre Bemühungen die Lage zu halten einstellen, damit nicht in letzter Sekunde die beiden Systeme gegeneinander arbeiten und vertraut darauf, dass das leichtere Raumfahrzeug sich an die Raumstation heran nimmt.
Was heißt das Inertial?
Inertial heißt im Raum feststehend, das heißt ohne Veränderung der Lage gegenüber einem globalen kosmologischen Bezugssystem. Normalerweise würden Raumstationen ja in eine optimale Position navigiert, um die Solarkollektoren mit Sonde zu versorgen oder vielleicht bestimmte Aufgaben mit Kameras auf der Erdoberfläche, das stabil ausführen zu können. Das stellt man alles ein. Man lässt die Raumstation driften und überlässt die Annäherung dann diesem leichteren, agileren Raumfahrzeug.
Und was greift dann ineinander?
Beim russischen System, um da zu bleiben, in dieser 10-Tonnen-Klasse, trifft auf relativ massives Objekt. Da greift dann eine Stange in einen Konus. Dieser Konus leitet die Stange dann in den Auffangbehälter, der die erste mechanische Kupplung vollzieht. Durch einen Gewindemechanismus wird dann das Raumfahrzeug entlang der Stange in diesen Konus hineingezogen und dann greifen Krampen und Haken ineinander, die beiden Raumfahrzeuge dann hermetisch und luftlich.
Und so wurde das auch schon von Anfang an gemacht?
So wird das auch schon.
Aber bei den ersten Raumstationen gab es auch keine Kameras, keine Live-Bilder, oder? Wie haben die sich denn überhaupt gefunden?
Na ja, die Kupplungen auch heute werden noch endlich über russische Bodenstationen durchgeführt. Das ist also eine der Bedingungen dieser Kupplungen, dass die russische Bodenstation Telemetrie empfangen kann und dann auch ein Kamerabild, was dann die Annäherung, so wie es ein Kommandant im Inneren des annähernden Raumfahrzeugs sieht, oder auch derjenige am Bord der Raumstation, der das Kamerabild empfängt, bei einem unbemannten Transporter. Dass man das also doch noch optisch auch begleitet.
So war das auch schon bei der ersten?
Das glaube ich nicht. Das weiß ich nicht. Die russischen Kommandanten sind traditionell, wenn es ein bemanntes Raumfahrzeug war, so ausgebildet, dass sie das auch mit Handsteuerung und einer Periskopsicht, also aus der Kapsel heraus, führt ein Periskop in Richtung auf das angeflogene Objekt und mit einfachen Skalen und Fadenkreuzen kann man das auch bewerkstelligen. Und zu meiner Überzeugung fast noch Treibstoff sparender als die automatische Variante, die ja irgendwo immer noch Überschwingungen hat. Die Amerikaner ja auch, die haben ihre Ankopplungen eigentlich, glaube ich, dann im Apollo-Zeitraum per Hand geflogen, also nicht automatisch.
Die Besatzung hätte ich jetzt fast vergessen. Das liegt daran, dass wir heute gerade an diesem Tag, wo wir jetzt diese Sendung aufnehmen, ist ja das Docking-Manöver der zweiten ATV-Mission steht jetzt an, sozusagen unmittelbar nach diesem Gespräch. Und da läuft es natürlich dann alles automatisch ab, wie das A in dem Namen ja zum Ausdruck bringt. Aber das erfordert schon eine gewisse Erfahrung, bis man überhaupt erst mal so weit kam, das auch voll automatisch durchführen zu können.
Das stieß auf erhebliche Skepsis und gerade dieser Frage, kann das automatische Transfervehikel ATV auch wirklich sicher im Umfeld der Raumstation agieren, hat also zu einem Großteil der technischen Testentwicklung geführt. Und was da ins ATV eingebaut werden musste und auch dann eingebaut wurde, das sind schon Duplex- und Triplex-Sicherheitsmechanismen, die greifen, wenn das ATV in der Nähe der Raumstation navigiert. Auf jeden Fall will man eine Kollision natürlich vermeiden. Auf jeden Fall muss in jeder Phase der Kopplung sichergestellt sein, dass ATV auch wieder eine sichere Distanz von der Raumstation einnimmt, wobei das Schicksal von ATV dann weniger eine Rolle spielt als das der Raumstation. Das ist also die Grundbedingung gewesen. Und ESA und die entwickelten Firmen mussten in vielen, vielen Punkten nachweisen, dass das erfüllt ist. Großartig geklappt beim ersten Flug. Da wurde noch mal auch in zwei Demonstrationen der Anflug in allen Phasen demonstriert. Und auch das Abbrechen und das Einnehmen einer sicheren Distanz wurde demonstriert. Das hat prima geklappt, sodass jetzt für das zweite Fahrzeug diese Tests, diese In-Orbit-Tests entfallen. Aber die Erfahrung aus dem ersten uns zeigt, dass ATV in der Lage ist, auch ohne Eingreifen einer menschlichen Besatzung dann im Umfeld der Raumstation sicher zu navigieren. Es gibt trotz allem immer noch ein Abbruchmechanismus durch die Besatzung, die kontrolliert den Anflug von ATV. Da gibt es einen Konus, der auf diese Kupplungsmechanismus dann zuführt. Und sobald ATV bis zu einer bestimmten Distanz diesen Konus verlässt, hat die Besatzung noch immer Gelegenheit, aus der optischen Überprüfung durch ein Kamerabild diesen Anflug abzubrechen.
Ja, kommen wir vielleicht mal zu der ersten, ja, wirklichen Raumstation, die, ja, ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich ein bisschen unangemessen diese Bezeichnung, aber die Mir ist ja auf jeden Fall die erste Raumstation gewesen, die weithin auch, wie soll ich sagen, eine gewisse Bekanntheit als solche überhaupt auch erst bekommen hat. Was unterschied denn die Mir von ihren Vorgängern im Wesentlichen? Was war denn so das Bahnbrechende an der russischen Raumstation Mir?
Die Mir-Raumstation hat ja von diesen Vorgängerexperimenten Sajut hauptsächlich alle diese Möglichkeiten geerbt. Also die Möglichkeit, die Raumstation im All auszubauen, das LEGO-Baukastensystem, dass man immer wieder Steine dransetzen kann. Sogar einige alte für Sajut gebaute Module sind dann auch noch umgebaut und zur Mir geschickt worden. Ich glaube, dass die Mir strukturell eben einfach von Anfang an größer ausgelegt war als die Sajut-Station. Das war jetzt kein Quantensprung, sondern es war tatsächlich eine kontinuierliche Weiterentwicklung. Und zu Unrecht, völlig zu Unrecht, ist der Start der Mir-Raumstation hier im Westen, ich hab jedenfalls nichts davon mitbekommen, nicht genügend gewürdigt und beachtet worden. Das war noch immer die Versuche offensichtlich der Russen, den Schock der Mondlandung und des verlorenen Wettlaufs zum Mond dann gut zu machen. So wurde das unter ferner liefen, alles abgelegt. Wie übrigens auch der erste Flug eines Deutschen. Keine große Sache auf der westlichen Seite der Mauer war. Das alles ist glücklicherweise erst später bekannt und gewürdigt worden und auch eingeflossen in unsere heutige Raumfahrt, wie wir sie haben. Etwa ab 1996. Also 1986 war die Welt damit beschäftigt, das Challenger-Unglück aufzuarbeiten, als der erste Block der Mehrraumstation gestartet wurde. Das war die bei Weitem tragischere und die weltbewegende Sache. Also was da passiert war, die Russen haben dann im Februar die MIR-Station begonnen mit einer unbemannten Start einer Proton-Rakete. Dann diesen Basisblock hochgeschafft und das dann kontinuierlich erweitert. Mir ist die MIR erst zu Ohren gekommen, als ein deutsches Experiment angekoppelt wurde, ein astrophysikalisches Röntgen-Experiment aus München, was dann mit dem Quant-Modul zur Raumstation gebracht wurde. Damals hieß es, Quant bringt Hexe zur MIR, weil das Ding hieß Hexe. Und das ist auch eine Zeit gelaufen. Da gab es doch mal so einen Rippel im Nachrichtenozean, dass das also existiert, so was wie Beginn der Raumstation.
Das heißt, die MIR, also auch die anderen, auch schon die Saaldiut-Missionen hatten Langzeitbesatzungen. Teilweise waren die sehr, ich weiß nicht, wie lange die da im Einzelnen besetzt waren, aber mehrere Wochen auf jeden Fall auch.
Das ging schon in die Monate. Da sind ja auch noch Flüge von MIR zur Sajut veranstaltet worden. Eine Zeit lang waren die ja parallel im All. Die Sajut-Elemente, schlagen sie mich die Nummer 7 oder was?
Ich glaube, es war die 7.
Die Sajut-Elemente und die beginnende MIR-Station und eine Besatzung hat das ja unternommen von der MIR dann zu diesem Eisschrank der Sajut-Station zu fliegen und die dann für eine Zeit in Betrieb zu nehmen, Sachen aus der Sajut dann auch über zur MIR wieder zu bringen. Die Legende hat es, dass das Foto von Yuri Gagarin aus der Sajut dann auch seinen Platz auf der MIR gefunden hat. Weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht bestätigen. Es gab ein Foto von Gagarin auf der MIR, ob das jetzt aus dem Eisschrank Sajut gerettet wurde.
Na ja, wenn das gefunden haben, kann ich mir das gut vorstellen. Auf jeden Fall, also es wurde sozusagen nochmal so richtig vor Ort ausgeschlachtet.
Es wurde nochmal, ja, und das war natürlich auch eine Demo, wie man zwischen zwei Raumstationen hin und her fliegen kann. Die Besatzung ist auch in Raumfahrerkreisen hochgelobt worden und hat also von diesem Extra die Mission sehr stark aufgewertet.
Die MIR war dann auch sehr lange oben, 15 Jahre, in Februar 86 gestartet. So und mit der Zeit wurde sie dann aber auch im Westen bekannter, weil ja dann eben mit dem Niedergang der Sowjetunion die internationale Kooperation auch extrem ausgebaut wurde. Es gab mehr und mehr gemeinsame Missionen mit den Deutschen, aber auch mit den Amerikanern. Das ist ja im Prinzip hier auch schon, es den Eindruck macht, als wäre das so ein bisschen auch mit die Basis gewesen für so eine internationale Kooperation, wie man sie jetzt schon für verständlicher ist.
Da sind einige gute Entscheidungen gefällt worden. Die erste gute Entscheidung war die der Russen, die Raumfahrt beizubehalten, also nicht in dem Zusammenbrechen der Wirtschaft dann auch noch den Raumfahrtetat reinzuschmeißen und zu sagen, okay, das Geld leisten wir uns jetzt nicht für so etwas Luxus oder Kulturmäßiges wie Raumfahrt. Ich glaube, die Zweckanwendung schon der Mir in den Zeiten, wo ich sie dann kennenlernte, war nicht mehr so gravierend. Zwar gab es Projekte, die sich um Landwirtschaft, Ozeanografie und Ähnliches von Bohr der Mir aus kümmerten, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das in Rubel und Kopeken in die Gesellschaft zurückfloss, sodass man also unbedingt diese Station halten musste, um eine Katastrophenabwehr oder Ernteprognosen oder Ähnliches zu gewährleisten. Nein, man hat sich dafür entschieden, glaube ich, erstens, weil es eine sehr große Affinität in Russland gibt für das Thema Raumfahrt, auch für die Möglichkeit, das Wissen im Raum immer zu erweitern, jenseits aller Propaganda. Das ist meine ehrliche Überzeugung, dass diese Dinge, die vielen Stunden, die vielen Überstunden, diesen Enthusiasmus, den die Leute bei magos dem Gehalt investiert haben, dass das aus einer echten Begeisterung auch für diese Sache entsteht und dass das nicht auf den russischen Raum begrenzt war, sondern dass man das in gewissen Seiten im Sinne für die Menschheit oder den Fortschritt der Menschheit tat. Das hat alles dazu geführt, dass dieses Flänzlein Raumfahrt diesen Zusammenbruch der Ökonomie, der Wirtschaft in Russland überlebt hat und heute ja nun konkurrenzfähig dasteht. Da gibt es einen Weltmarkt, der nicht unbedingt in einem Bebandenraumfahrt ist. Es gibt einen Weltmarkt für Transport ins All. Es gibt einen Weltmarkt für Aufklärung im weitesten Sinne Fotografien der Erde, Spektrale, Durchmusterung, wo Russland ja auch mitspielt. Und der sichtbare Ausläufer dieser Sache war eben der Erhalt der MIR-Station. Der letzte Kosmonaut, wer erinnert sich nicht, das ist der Krickerloft, der nicht runtergeholt werden konnte, weil der Staat nicht mehr in der Lage war genug, Abholraketen hochzuschicken und und und. Also das sind natürlich Dinge, die wunderbar auch die Story der MIR im Gedächtnis verankerten und die letztlich dazu führten, dass wir heute in dieser Kooperation auch zusammen sind. Interessant war es dann, als der Shuttle mit MIR in Verbindung gebracht wurde. Dafür war er nie konzipiert, also das amerikanische Space Shuttle. Auf einmal gab es aber schon eine Raumstation, die das Shuttle anfliegen konnte, bevor überhaupt die amerikanischen Pläne einer Raumstation so gestaltet angenommen hat, dass man das erste Element hätte ins All bringen können. Und da haben die Amerikaner dann auch gut zugegriffen. In einer ersten Phase haben sie einfach mal kennengelernt, was heißt es denn, eine Raumstation zu betreiben. Ein Shuttle-Flug, das hatte man im Griff 10, 14 Tage. Planung, das war eine hochkonzentrierte Phase. Ich hab selbst faszinierend das bei der D2-Emission mitgemacht, wie dann alle Experten an einem Ort zusammenkommen, den Shuttle-Flug unterstützen und da das Maximum rausholen. Aber eine Raumstation ist ganz was anderes. Das sind 365 Tage. Da muss man also mit langem Atem eigentlich rangehen. Und das haben die Amerikaner in der Phase 1, in dem sie auch Astronauten an die Raumstation schickten, dann kennengelernt in einer Phase 2, wo dann ja der Beginn der Raumstation und der Aufbauarbeiten der eigentlichen Internationalen Raumstationen in Angriff genommen. Phase 3 war dann die Nutzung derselben. Das brachte auf wunderbare Weise also die Möglichkeiten des Shuttle, großer Nutzerstransport ins All, vor allen Dingen großer Runtertransport, auch wieder die Möglichkeit, Sachen heil runterzubringen. Ins Spiel plus die Erfahrung der Russen und auch die Möglichkeit, ein zweites Standbein zu haben. Denken Sie an die Zeit, wo der Shuttle nicht die Raumstation anflug ab 2003, als Columbia tragisch in der Hochatmosphäre explodiert war und die Shuttle nicht fliegen konnten. Wie wären wir zur Raumstation gekommen? Wie hätten wir die Raumstation am Leben erhalten, wenn nicht durch das andere Standbein, durch die Soyuz-Kapsel? Also da ist eine gute Entscheidung für die internationale Kooperation gefällt worden. Eine weitere Entscheidung auf der deutschen Seite war es, da mitzumachen. Wir waren nicht die ersten. Als ich kam, waren die Franzosen schon lange da. Die Österreicher hatten Monate vorher eigentlich schon diese Gelegenheit beim Schopfer ergriffen und haben uns auch immer wissen lassen, dass sie das toll fanden, dass sie die ersten waren, die deutschsprachig im Sternstädtchen zu einer Flugchance kamen. Aber wir haben uns dann wirklich auch gut eingefreundet. Das war eine weitere gute Entscheidung. Die dritte gute Entscheidung war, die von Europa an der Internationalen Raumstation teilzunehmen. Aus all diesen Möglichkeiten, der starken deutschen Position, der europäischen Entscheidung, davon leben wir heute noch.
Bleiben wir trotzdem noch mal bei der Mir. Ich finde das ein spannendes Thema. Nicht zuletzt deshalb, weil du ja auch selbst oben warst, 1997. Also Klaus-Gedrich Vlade war dann der Erste Deutsche auf der Mir.
Ja, nicht der Erste im All.
Ja, auf der Mir ganz konkret. Und du warst dann sozusagen die Nummer Zwei.
Ja, ich war als Reiter noch zwischen, dafür nicht vergessen. Der ein bisschen anders sein Ticket bekommen hat eben von der ESA. Das war historisch irgendwo noch, lief das parallel. Das Deutsche Astronautenchor, das ESA Astronautenchor, obwohl wir auch schon viele Dinge ausgetauscht haben. Die Teams teilweise auch schon füreinander gearbeitet haben. Auch viele der Experimente wurden vom einen auf den anderen Flug dann übertragen. Aber das wurde als ESA-Flug 1995 dann gehandhabt. Da war dann Thomas für immerhin ein halbes Jahr fast um.
Aber wie lief das jetzt? Was, so ab dem Moment, wo man weiß, man ist jetzt ausgewählt, soll losgehen? Die Ausbildung gab es ja vorher schon. Also bevor jetzt sozusagen die Entscheidung tatsächlich fiel. Wie intensiv muss man sich damit beschäftigen? Wie viel weiß man über diese Raumstation? Wie viel muss man wissen, bis man da hoch kann?
Das klingt dann vielleicht vermessen, wenn ich sage, dass die Haupthürde erst mal das Russische war, das uns ja nicht so mitgegeben war. Sowohl Klaus-Dietrich Vlade als auch ich sind in westlichen, also westlichen Teil Deutschlands durch die Schule gelaufen. Da war Russisch eigentlich eher exotisch. Und aus den bekannten Gründen. Das heißt, wir mussten uns erst mal intensiv russisch orientieren, weil die Möhraumstation tatsächlich eine russische Raumstation war. Die Dokumentation war in Russisch, der Funk-Sprechverkehr beim Start, also Flugphase zur Möhre, aber auch am Bord der Möhre war russisch. Ich kann mir auch keinen Weg vorstellen, wie man in eine Besatzung mit einem Dolmetscher hineinkommt als anerkanntes Mitglied. Ich meine, der Dolmetscher, der fliegt ja dann nicht mit. Mein Ehrgeiz war es also, im Russischen eigentlich schon auf den Stand zu kommen, dass ich mich als vollwertiges Besatzungsmitglied dann auch identifizierte. Das heißt mehr als nur technisches Radebrechen, mehr als nur ein paar Nummern in den Raum werfen oder Dadada zu sagen oder sowas. Und das habe ich in der ersten Phase des Trainings eben sehr stark auch dann betont und sicherlich auch profitiert davon, dass es nicht meine erste Fremdsprache war, die ich als Erwachsener lernte. Also da hat man auch seine Methodik und sucht sich schon die Wege ins Russische hinein. Dank einer sehr guten Lehrerin haben Klaus und ich dann diese Hürde eigentlich auch gemeistert, sodass wir dann auch den technischen Teil verstehen konnten. Ich kam nun von der wissenschaftlichen Seite, Radioastronomie, ich habe mich mit sicherlich auch technischen und wissenschaftlichen Fragestellungen auseinandergesetzt. Klaus kam von der Testfliegerei, der hatte also operationell nachgewiesen natürlich exzellente Fähigkeiten. Und das Training war jetzt so, dass wir uns angleichen mussten. Das ist der Teil, wo ich also operationell dann auch auf die Höhe kommen musste. Natürlich für mich die Herausforderung war, für ihn war es dann die Zweckbestimmung des Fluges, nämlich auch die wissenschaftliche Seite, um das Ganze kennenzulernen, plus das allgemeine kennenlernte System der Raumstation in dem Umfang, wie wir es brauchten. Wir sollten ja da oben jetzt keine Wartungsarbeiten ausführen. Wir sollten ja jetzt nicht die Raumstation über längere Zeit begleiten, sondern uns nur sicher in dieser Umgebung dann auch bewegen können. Wir beide haben eigentlich mit viel Freude und langen Nachtstunden natürlich auch diese Aufgabe angegangen. Zum Zeitpunkt des Fluges waren wir beide also auch in der Lage, diesen Flug sicher und mit Profit auch für die Kollegen aus der russischen Besatzung dann auszuführen. Das hat sich eigentlich gelohnt und dieses Training hat sich dann auch später nochmal wiederholt. Das war eine Phase von etwa 18 Monaten, in der wir intensiv in Russland auch gelebt haben und uns dem Russischen und diesen Systemgedanken dann auch aussetzen mussten. Ich glaube, ohne das geht es nicht. Also wenn man das sich anlesen will, das war damals eigentlich nicht die Tradition, dass das so verschriftlicht wurde, dass man anschaulich dann in dieses Thema reinkam. Beschweige denn, dass man das Russische hätte lesen müssen. Da musste man da sein, da musste man mit den Trainern auch intensiv durch diese Kurse gehen. So war das Training angelegt. Wir haben von der Tafel abgeschrieben. Also russische Formeln und Schlagwörter und Ähnliches in unser Heft schön kopiert. PowerPoint, das war noch Zukunft.
Jetzt kommen wir langsam auch in die Fragestellung der Funktionsweise der Mir. Wenn man sich zu einem komplexen Thema nähert, so Raumstation, wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Ich meine, da gibt es sicherlich eine Menge Dinge, die man jetzt einfach von seiner Basisausbildung her entweder schon gehört hat oder die sich, weil man eben Physik kennt, weiß, welche Kernprobleme auch so gemeistert werden müssen, sodass auch vielleicht die Lösungen dafür naheliegend sind. Jetzt haben die Russen aber sehr viel Erfahrung aufgebaut in diesem Bereich und sicherlich auch schon Probleme gelöst, an die man vielleicht zuerst gar nicht denkt. Auch die Russen am Anfang wahrscheinlich nicht dran gedacht haben, bis sie dann auf das Problem stießen. Wenn man sich jetzt so intensiv dann mit der Mir, die ja im Prinzip mindestens die 8., 9. Generation von Raumstationen war, damit dann beschäftigt, stößt man dann nicht auch laufend auf solche Lösungsansätze für bestimmte Sachen, wo man sich denkt, Hammer, wie haben die das, war das jetzt irgendwie so, also das ist irgendwie so eine bestimmte, geniale, einfache Lösung, so Hacker-Lösung, wo man sich denkt, eigentlich total einfach. Das erste Mal, wo ich jetzt über das Problem nachdenke, wäre mir eine total komplexe Lösung eingefallen und dann hat irgendjemand nur hier ein Kabel von A nach B gezogen und die Sache funktioniert auch.
Ich habe großen Respekt bekommen von der russischen Ingenieurleistung, denn was einfach aussah, war unter russischen Bedingungen vielleicht gar nicht so einfach zu bewerkstelligen. Erstens ist das immer eine Mangelwirtschaft gewesen, das heißt, man konnte nicht aus dem vollen Schöpfen schon gar nicht bestellen, was man haben wollte, sondern musste mit dem Folieb nehmen, was da war, respektive was angewendet werden konnte und viele dieser Elemente machten den Eindruck, als ob sie direkt aus dem U-Boot-Bau eigentlich in den Raum geschossen wurden. Und die Lösungen, die man also in abgeschlossenen Lebenserhaltungssystemen, auch anderswo auf der Welt, schon mal gefunden hatte, die wurden auch ins All transportiert, wenn sie denn übersetzbar waren. In dem Moment, wo es dann um die Spezifika des Weltraums ging, wie mache ich Wassertrennung von Luft in Schwerelosigkeit, wie pumpe ich Sachen, gerade was also auch Flüssigkeiten angeht, von A nach B, da muss ich sagen, dann waren auf einmal die Weltraumlösungen entwickelt, also mit einer ungeheuren Ingenuität, mit Erfindungsreichtum, was da schon eingebaut war, was eben auch diese Langzeit-Komponente beinhaltet. Das Ganze also nicht nur für einen Moment und für 14 Tage dann funktionierte, sondern das ist auch schon auf die damals vorgesehene Laufzeit vor fünf Jahren, die hat sich ja dann nachher auf, ich weiß nicht was, 15 Jahre verlängerte Möhrstation gerichtet war. Das waren schon verblüffende Erkenntnisse, was da schon an Ingenieur-Vorleistungen drinsteckte in diesem System und wie die arbeiteten. Eins haben die Russen nur nicht, Traditionen auf Astronauten zu hören. Das muss man also ehrlich so sagen, wenn wir sagten, das ist aber unbequem und der Hebel ist aber sehr schwergängig und ergonomisch ungünstig angebracht. Das haben, glaube ich, schon 10 Besatzungen vor uns gesagt. Das ist uns nicht alleine aufgefallen. Die Änderungen nahmen immer sehr lange Zeit oder in Anspruch oder passierte gar nicht. Das war so ein ständiges Klagen, was wir da hatten. Ja, ich weiß, die Russen lassen lieber eine Besatzung um Unvollkommenes herumarbeiten und Unbequemlichkeiten vielleicht auch in Kauf nehmen, als dass sie das Design komplett neu anfangen und vielleicht nicht besser werden als das, was da ist. Das ist sicherlich das entscheidende Unterscheidungsmerkmal zum amerikanischen System, wo Astronautenmeinungen sofort eine Reihe von Designänderungen oder Prozeduränderungen...
Kann das vielleicht das Element sein, was die Amerikaner immer so auf diesen Pfad bringt, ist dann total ausgeklügelt und pfiffig zu machen, aber wo man dann auch Gefahr läuft, sich in zu viel Komplexität zu verrennen?
Na ja, die Leistung der Amerikaner ist natürlich auch einzigartig.
Nein, ich wollte das ja auch nicht mindern, aber wir hatten das ja schon beim Space Shuttle, der sozusagen unter seiner Universität...
Wenn ich mir die Toilette anschaue, ist das tatsächlich der Fall. Ich meine, in Europa käme niemand auf die Idee, in eine Toilette einen Schredder einzubauen, der also die festen Bestandteile dessen, was man auf der Toilette von sich gibt, an die Wände schleudert, um sie dann da auszufrieren und dann auf dem Boden alles weiter zu unternehmen, um das Ganze wieder zu säubern. Das ist etwas, was man in jeder amerikanischen Küche findet, dass man also die Gemüseabfälle durch den Abfluss hier hackt, weil da so ein kleiner Schredder da ist. Das Ding ist natürlich beliebig störanfällig und hat bestimmt Riesenaufwand erfordert, um es Weltraumtauglich und verlässlich zu machen, auch nur für einen 14-Tage-Flug. Für die Zeit, wo man eine Raumstation im All betreibt, ist dieses Thema völlig untauglich. Die Russen sind mit der einfachsten Lösung gekommen, das Ganze in feste Behälter zu packen, was man loswerden will und irgendwann wegzuschmeißen. Das sind dann schon Ansätze, die unterschiedlich sind. Auch vom Design her und von der Generation von Geräten, die an Start gebracht wird, sich sehr stark unterscheiden. In Russland ändert sich die ganze Technik wirklich nur sehr langsam, während in Amerika der nächste Batch, der nächste Cycle, das nächste Upgrade relativ schnell eingeführt wird.
Kommen wir doch mal konkret zum Aufbau der MIA. Wie ist diese Raumstation aufgebaut gewesen?
Sie ist aufgebaut im Baukassensystem, ich zitiere mal wieder Lego, dass man in der Lage ist, einst nach dem anderen diese Geräte an die Raumstation heranzuführen. Im Gegensatz zu dem, was wir an Bord der Internationalen Raumstation sind, sind die meisten dieser Geräte selbst Raumflugkörper gewesen für eine Freiflugphase. Das heißt, sie haben eine Elektroversorgung nach Ablösen vom Trägersystem. Sie haben eine Navigation und eine Avionik, die ihnen ermöglicht, das schon bestehende Objekt der Raumstation anzufliegen und dann auch eine Kopplung zu machen. Diese Elemente müssen also in diesen russischen Elementen überall, in diesen russischen Modulen eingebaut sein, damit überhaupt diese Raumstation wachsen konnte. Da kommt es dann zu ganz cleveren Lösungen. Wenn dann ein Modul vielleicht die Kapazität des Docking-Stutzens erschöpft hat, wenn er einfach zu viel mechanisch schon abgenutzt ist, dann führt man mit einem letzten Akt ein neues Modul heran, was in diesen Docking-Stutzen eingreift und hinten dran wieder einen neuen, frischen Docking-Stutzen hat. Diese Möglichkeiten hat man natürlich in diesem Baukastensystem, die ganze Sache nicht endgültig verloren zu geben, sondern durch Ergänzungen. Das ist jetzt auch nicht theoretisch, sondern praktisch gemacht worden. Da ist eine große Variabilität aus Grundelementen. Zylinder, Kugel, Kegel, das sind die Elemente, die dann endlos variiert wurden und in immer wieder neuen Zusammenschweißungen an der Raumstation angekoppelt wurden. Um einen Basisblock herum, der schon alle lebenswichtigen Dinge beinhaltet. Im Wesentlichen ist das so, dass der Safe Haven, solange der läuft, kann die Besatzung da auch existieren.
Das heißt, da liegt die Besatzung im Wesentlichen? Da wird geschlafen?
Nicht unbedingt, das ging dann auch in die Module. Aber die Module sind Ergänzungen und Komfortergänzungen, dass man die Toilette eben nicht neben dem Essentisch hat, sondern dass sie in ein entfernteres Modul ausgelagert ist. Ein Modul, was ein bisschen ruhiger ist, auch von den Ventilatoren her oder von den Geräten, die da arbeiten, sodass man vielleicht da ein bisschen besser schläft als im Zentralbereich. Diese Dinge sind nach und nach gekommen, aber sie wären auch ohne Verlust wieder auf den endlichen Kernteil zu reduzieren gewesen. Das haben wir ja gesehen, als die mir von diesem Raumfahrzeug getroffen wurde und eins der Hauptstromlieferanten, nämlich das Spektromodul dann leckschlug. Man hat es geschafft, den Rest der Raumstation weiter zu betreiben, auch ohne in dieses Spektromodul hinein zu müssen. Gut, man hat den Strom dann noch verwendet, indem man Durchleitungskabel durch die luftdichte Tür gelegt hat. Aber für die Zeit, wo das nicht zur Verfügung stand, ist die mir auch weiter betrieben worden. Also sicherlich nicht mit dem Anspruch, 100 Prozent Funktionsfähigkeit zu jeder Zeit zu gewährleisten, aber eine Kernüberlebensfähigkeit immer zu gewährleisten, ist die mir eigentlich ein gutes Beispiel gewesen.
Wie kommen wir denn jetzt überhaupt hoch? Der Flug ging von Baikonur aus?
Der Flug geht von Baikonur aus. Das hat sich eigentlich auch mit den neueren Typen der Soyuz-Kapsel nicht geändert. Das ist noch immer auf das lebensnotwendige beschränkt. Die Besatzung nimmt in einem sogenannten Rückkehrteil Platz mit drei Leuten auf Pritschen, die in die Körper geformt sind, nebeneinander, in ihren Raumanzügen. Da wird auch kein Kompromiss gemacht. Nach einem schwärzigen Verlust einer Besatzung durch eine Fehlfunktion von Ventilen, die dann auf dem Rückflug erstickt ist, hat man also absolut dann die Raumanzugpflicht eingeführt und die entsprechend umgebaut. Dadurch wird es natürlich auch sehr eng. Das ist gar keine Frage. Da ist überhaupt kein Platz mehr. Die Kapazität dieser zusätzlichen Besatzung zu den lebensnotwendigen Sachen einer Soyuz ist 150 Kilogramm, das ist nichts. Das müssen dann Transportraumschiffe schon vorher hochgeschafft haben, was man da braucht. So waren auch unsere Schlafsäcke zum Beispiel. Viele dieser Berechnungen zum Opfer. Wir waren also ohne Schlafsäcke unterwegs. Und es wurde arg kalt. In der Kapsel? In dieser Kapsel, als wir da auf dem Weg zu einer Raumstation waren.
Was heißt arg?
Wärmlich gefroren.
Was heißt denn das arg kalt?
Ark kalt heißt, dass man ja nicht heizen kann da unbedingt, weil das verbraucht Elektroenergie. Und die hat man während dieser Phase nicht, wo man die Bahnen der Soyuzkapsel mit den Satzungsmitgliedern und die Raumstationen miteinander angleicht. Und so mussten wir mit dem Volleyb nehmen, was wir da hatten, ein paar Kleidungsstücke. Wir haben uns dann alles übereinander angezogen, was wir da hatten, an Strümpfen etc. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab die Temperatur nicht gemessen. Also sicherlich nicht so, dass jetzt Wasser auskondensierte das wäre. Aber es war sicherlich keine 22 Grad, es war ja 16 oder 18. Diese Kompromisse macht man einfach und dann setzt man die Besatzung da rein und hofft darauf, dass alle Systeme nach dem Start in Betrieb genommen werden. Die Solarpaneele entfalten sich, um für die autonome Flugphase Strom heranzuschaffen. Die Dichtigkeit der Kapsel wird überprüft. Vor allen Dingen wird schon mal auch der Kopplungsmechanismus überprüft. Denn wenn der nicht funktioniert, wenn wir da größere Fehlfunktionen voraussehen im Kopplungsmechanismus, kann man den Flug genauso gut abbrechen. Das bringt nichts mit der Solis-Kapsel, noch ein paar Tage durchs All zu fliegen. Das sind die ersten Schritte, die schon zeigen, wie zielgerichtet das Ganze ist.
Was geht einem bei diesem Start durch den Kopf?
Bei dem Start ging mir durch den Kopf jetzt nur funktionieren. Ich hatte ein traumatisches Erlebnis bei den Übungen am Boden in der Originalkapsel. Wir werden also einige Tage vor dem Start mit der Originalkapsel vertraut gemacht. An einem dieser Tage sollten uns dann auch mit den Ohrmannzügen in der Kapsel schonmal anschnallen. Dann werden die Sitze eingerichtet. Das vergrüngert den Raum, der zur Verfügung steht, noch mal und mir flutschte dann einer der Sicherheitsgurte durch die Schnalle. Das mussten wir dann mit Hilfe meines Kommandanten korrigieren und das war sehr schweißtreibend, sich in dieser engen Umgebung so zu winden, dass wir an diese Schnalle kamen und dann mit den Bahnschüten hin, die diese Schnalle wieder einfädelten, sodass ich mich ordentlich anschnallen konnte. Das war ein Erlebnis, was mir sagte, also am Stachtag bist du es nicht, der hier diese Sache zum Abbruch führt. Du konzentrierst dich auf deine Aufgaben. Da war auch eigentlich dann kein Raum für grundsätzliche Überlegungen. Willst du das denn auch noch oder ist das nicht so gefährlich?
Da ist man ja nur noch Maschine.
Da ist man über diesen Punkt hinaus. Da hat man zu viel trainiert. Ich habe noch nicht erlebt, dass einer sich an der Stachtrante umgedreht hat und dem Backup-Mann gesagt hat, komm, das ist mir zu gefährlich.
Wenn man so weit gekommen ist, dann macht man natürlich keinen Schritt zurück.
Das ist auch kein blindes Vertrauen. Das ist wirklich auch begründet. Wir haben also sehr sorgfältig auch die Rettungssysteme der Sojus kennengelernt. Wir sind mit den Leuten zusammen getroffen, die die Sojus ausrüsten. Die haben den Eindruck gewonnen, dass da alles Menschenmögliche getan ist, um Unfälle auszuschließen. Und wenn Unfälle passieren, sie überlebbar zu machen.
Ist ab da alles so, wie man sich das gedacht hat? Ist die Belastung durch den Staat zum Beispiel dieser unglaubliche Druck, der auf einem lastet?
Da kann man natürlich noch aus der Zentrifugennau profitieren, wo man also gelernt hat, dieser Belastung zu atmen, die entsprechende Bewegung auszuführen, die man ausführen muss, sich dazu entspannen. Für mich war die wichtigste Aussage nach all den Trainings, die wir gemacht haben, die der Ärzte, die sagten, vom körperlichen her bist du absolut in der Lage, alle berechenbaren Einflüsse, die während des Fluges auf dich zukommen, zu überleben. Das hat mich begleitet. Es mag ungewöhnlich sein, du wirst hin und her geschmissen, es werden Kräfte wirken, dein Vestibularorgan wird völlig verwirrt sein durch diese Andruckkräfte. Dann auf einmal setzt die Stufe aus, dann denkt man auch, jetzt bin ich im freien Fall, dann kommt die nächste Stufe, dann wird man wieder irgendwo anders hingeschmissen, man hat überhaupt keine Orientierungspunkte. Alles das ist ungewöhnlich, aber nicht gefährlich. Also nicht lebensgefährlich. Auch bei der Rückkehr, wo es noch viel Ärger zugeht, da hat mich dieser Gedanke begleitet. Und das gibt so eine gewisse Gelassenheit, dass man sagt, okay, dann lässt es halt mit dir geschehen. Und es wird schon vorbeigehen. Etwas, was ich auch von meinen russischen Kollegen kennengelernt habe. Wir sind da viel zu nervös, wir Westler.
Und gab es dann an der Blauen Donau irgendwie?
Nein, weder haben wir den Knochen getroffen, der sich dann in die Raumstation verwandelt, noch war es schöne Blaue Donau. Ich sag ja, was vom Film hängen bleibt, sind Ledersessel und gepflegte Drinks. Zum Moonlight Serenade nicht zu nehmen. Also es ist technisch, es ist kahl, es ist das Notwendigste. Es ist etwas, was ich vermutlich nur auf einer Polarstation beim Überwintern oder so oder beim U-Boot analog erleben könnte. Und man muss seine Ansprüche an Design und Schönheit und Ästhetik sehr runterfahren. Zur Raumstation haben wir zwei Tage gebraucht. Das liegt einfach am russischen Raum, an der Raumfahrtinfrastruktur, den Flug ja nicht rund um die Welt begleitet, sondern bei Überflügen über Russland. Die nötigen Daten gewinnt, so macht man nach und nach Korrekturen, die einen sicher am zweiten Tag zur Raumstation führen. Die eigentlich angetriebene Phase ist 8,5 Minuten. Danach bringt es so ist das Kunststück fertig, sofort in eine fast zirkuläre Umlaufbahn zu kommen. Normalerweise müsste man nach einem halben Orbit noch mal eine Korrektur machen, das sagt also die Ballistik. Das macht es sowieso aber nicht. Und wir machen unterwegs nur zwei, drei Manöver, die uns also die erwiesenen Korrekturmöglichkeiten angeben, um auf die Raumstation am zweiten Tag da noch anzufliegen.
Dann fliegt man hinterher.
Dazwischen ist nichts, dazwischen ist Ruhe, dazwischen ist Freude aus des Lebens.
Man sitzt da wie so eine Sardiner im Weltall, keine Musik und auch sonst kein Entertainment. Kann man sich nicht so unterhalten?
Unterhalten kann man sich natürlich. Wir legen ja auch irgendwann die Raumanzüge ab und werden dann nicht mit Kopfhörern jetzt rumlaufen, aber was heißt rumlaufen, herumschweben. Wir versammeln uns in einem etwa drei Meter Durchmesser großen Kuppel. Da ist der Docking-Mechanismus untergebracht und auch die Nutzflaschen, die wenige Nutzflaschen, die wir haben. Da gibt es einen Wasserspender, der so lauwarmes Wasser liefert. Es gibt ein paar Dosen und Tuben mit Quark oder Dosen mit Fisch. Das ist so die Nahrung, kein Herd, kein Nichts. In dieser Kugel befindet sich natürlich auch die Toilette. Alles das muss man mit den zwei Kollegen dann durchstehen. Da kann man nicht viele Ansprüche stellen. Getragen wird das Ganze von dem Ziel, unsere Mission an Bord der Raumstation zu fliegen und uns nicht über Unbequemlichkeiten des Hotels zu vertragen.
Als ihr dann angekommen seid, gab es ja schon eine Langzeitbesatzung. Da sind immer drei, zwei oder drei vor Ort. Und dann kommen noch mal drei dazu, die für eine bestimmte Zeit zusätzlich an Bord sein können. Aber so dauerhaft, das ist mir nur auf drei Personen ausgelegt gewesen. Nachdem dann das Docking stattgefunden hat, kommt man dann so rein.
Eine riesen Umstellung. Wir sind von zehn Kubikmeter, die auch noch durch Geräte und Verpackungen und was weiß ich weggenommen wurden, sind wir auf einen riesen Raum getroffen. Und das war der erste und verblüffende Eindruck, den ich eigentlich hatte, dass ich völlig orientierungslos war. Wir haben sicherlich Stunde um Stunde dem Bodenmodell der Mir zugebracht. Aber das ist am Boden hintereinander und nebeneinander angeordnet und nicht in dieser Dreidimensionalität, die man da oben hat. Zweitens, was man bemerkte, war der stechende Geruch, der aber nicht aus der Mir kommt, sondern aus dem Koppelungsknoten, der vorher ja dem Weltall ausgesetzt ist. Und Weltall wirkt auf diese Metalloberflächen wie ein ganz brutaler Hobel. Das heißt, das ist rohes Metall, was da riecht. Das durch Sauerstoffradikale und durch andere auftreffende Moleküle also sehr stark beansprucht wurde. Dieser Geruch begleitet einen während des Durchfliegens von der Soyuz-Kapsel in die Raumstation. Das ist sehr prägend für die erste Zeit. Der verfliegt dann. Relativ schnell gewöhnt man sich schon an den Stuben-Mief. Ich hab nichts mehr geochen nachher. Wenn dann überhaupt war der Geruch technisch, Talcum, eingepuderte Dichtungen, Metallabrieb. Da musste man jetzt wirklich schon an den aufgehängten Socken vom Kollegen vorbeifliegen, der nach dem Sport an seine Socken trocknete, um überhaupt diesen Turnhallen- oder Umkleideraumeffekt zu haben, der ja so oft beschrieben wird, der da oben herrschen sollte. Wenn das tatsächlich der Fall wäre, dass es da oben nach Mensch und Turnhalle und Mief riecht, ist Gefahr im Verzuge, weil dann das Lebenserhaltungssystem einfach nicht ausreicht, um wieder die Atmosphäre auf Null zu bringen. Und damit haben wir Mikroben, die überhandnehmen, damit haben wir Gefährdung von Maschinen und Oberflächen, die dann angegriffen werden. Und damit ist also das Ende einer Raumstation schon eingeläutet. Wenn die erst mal die Mikroorganismen übernehmen, dann ist es schon zu spät. Dann braucht eine Raumstation. Da muss wirklich das Luftreinigungssystem vorher eingreifen. Und damit ist auch der Geruch da oben eigentlich nicht so, wie oft beschrieben.
Ist das eine schwierige Angelegenheit, so ein Luftreinigungssystem? Was muss denn da geleistet werden? Um atemberre Luft zu machen.
Wir sind dem Luftreinigungssystem sehr dankbar, weil wir am 14. Tag unserer Mission ein Feuer zu bekämpfen hatten. Ein Feuer, das sehr viel Rauch, Dampf, Qualm, Schwebetalchen freisetzte. Und mit dem musste dieses Luftreinigungssystem in der Zeit fertig werden, wo wir uns mit Gasmasken vielleicht noch davor schützen konnten, aber wo wir auch absehbarerweise keine Gasmasken mehr zur Verfügung hatten danach. Und ich muss sagen, dass auch damals, 1997, war das Luftreinigungssystem der MIR in der Lage, nach einem solchen Mega-Ereignis wie einem Brand am Bord, innerhalb von zwei, drei Stunden die Luft wieder atembern.
Was war denn der Auslöser für diesen Brand? Was ist denn da schiefgelaufen?
Anlass war eigentlich die Tatsache, dass wir mit sechs Leuten das Lebensreinigungssystem der MIR überlasten würden. Deshalb wird in diesem Falle der Sauerstoff an Bord durch Verbrauchspatronen erzeugt. Das sind etwa 30 cm hohe Zylinder, die ein Lithiumperchlorat, also eigentlich auch schon fast eine explosive Mischung, im Inneren haben, was durch ein kontrolliertes Abbrennen Sauerstoff von sich gibt. Normalerweise läuft dieser Vorgang über 30 Minuten. Man setzt die Reaktion in Gang, indem mit einer kleinen Initialzündung Energie in das System gepumpt wird. Dann läuft dieser chemische Vorgang ab, der Sauerstoff freisetzt, die Patrone wird warm und das ist aber selbst erhalten. Der Sauerstoff, der dann austritt, wird mit der Umgebungsluft gemischt. In unserem Falle war das also eine Routine. Wir mussten diese Patrone 2-3 Mal am Tag dann in Betrieb nehmen. Das haben wir dann auch an einem Sonntagabend nochmal gemacht. Das war mein Kollege Alexander Lesutkin, der die Patrone dann normal in den Ventilator einspannte, der die Luft verteilt in Betrieb nahm. Dann schoss ihm eine Stichflamme aus dieser Patrone entgegen.
Nach dem Einsetzen?
Nach dem Einsetzen bei der Inbetriebnahme. Durch irgendwelche Alterungs- oder Lagerungsumstände hatte sich diese Patrone so gewandelt, dass die Chemikalie im Inneren, statt langsam abzubrennen, auf einmal abbrannte. Wir haben also mit einem Schneidbrenner zu tun gehabt. Eine sauerstoffreichen Flamme, die mit hoher Temperatur aus dieser Patrone austrat. Sofort die Umgebung natürlich verdampfte. Metallteilchen, Aluminium, alles Mögliche wurde da in Mitleidenschaft gezogen und setzte Qualm und Rauch frei. Ich hab das sogar als Erster gesehen von dem anderen Abteil der Raumstation, wo wir mit dem Rest der Besatzung um den Essenszisch versammelt waren. Ich glaube, dass du das also auch sofort in Reaktionen einsetzst. Valery Korso und der Kommandant versuchten, das Feuer zu ersticken, flog dahin, versuchte das Feuer mit seiner Jacke zu ersticken, aber es war natürlich aussichtslos, weil der Sauerstoff von ihnen kam, damit also mit ersticken gar nichts zu machen. Und dann sind wir alle unserer Routine nachgegangen, nämlich Selbstschutz, Gasmasken aufsetzen. Ich bin in mein Modul, in Anführungszeichen, wo ich schlief, geflogen, hab da die Maske geholt, weil jeder hat auch einen zugewiesenen Notfallsatz, sozusagen, und da wollte ich natürlich nicht den von jemand anderes plündern. Und als wir dann alle wieder zusammen kamen, war schon die Luft sehr vernebelt, dann mit Feuerlöschern, hat dann die Valérie hauptsächlich, und die Ingenieure haben dann versucht, durch Wasserspray oder durch Schaum diesen Brand zu löschen. Das hat erstmal nicht geklappt. Und erst als wir vermutlich so viel Wasser auf diese Patrone gesprüht hatten, dass die Temperatur der Reaktion dann so weit runtergekühlt war, dass sie zum Stillstand kam, haben wir dann diese Sache löschen können. Oder sie ist einfach ausgebrannt. Und ich hab da also auch jetzt im Nachhinein keine Informationen bekommen, was zuerst eingetreten ist. Auf jeden Fall war der Brand gelöscht, aber jetzt hatten wir Wasserdampf reichlich in der Raumstation. Wir hatten diese Brandrückstände, den Dampf, den Rauch. Auf armes Länge konnte man wirklich nichts sehen. Und wir haben dann angefangen, diese Luftreinigungssysteme auf Max zu schalten, alles mit einer Gasmaske angetan. Wir wussten die Gasmasken, wenn es gut geht, zwei Stunden geben die uns Reserve.
Gab es denn zu dem Zeitpunkt gerade Funk-Kontakt?
Nein, kein Funk-Kontakt. Das war alles mitten in der Mitte von ruhigen Orbits, wo wir also keinerlei Funk-Kontakt zu erwarten haben. Wir haben dann über Amateur-Funk unsere Story erzählt. Wir haben also zu Whom It Made Concern einen Ruf abgesetzt. Und die Amateur-Funker sind ja auch überall auf der Welt, Tag und Nacht irgendwo im Einsatz. Und die Mir war damals sicherlich ein attraktives Objekt, um sie abzuhören. Das ist tatsächlich auch aufgefangen worden. Wir haben jetzt kein Madey Madey gefunkt, aber wir haben gesagt, bitte informiert das Flugleitzentrum in Moskau, dass bei uns zwar was passiert ist, aber dass es relativ grimpflich ausgegangen ist. Und wir versuchen jetzt erst mal, hier weiter zu arbeiten.
Wie lange war es dann noch hin bis zum nächsten erwarteten Funkkontakt?
Also bis zum erwarteten Funkkontakt, würde ich mal sagen, war es noch neun Stunden. Und die haben das dann vorgezogen. Die haben in Kamchatka irgendwo eine Station in Betrieb genommen und haben sich also schon um 6 Uhr morgens dann gemeldet statt 8 Uhr. Und dadurch hatten wir also dann die erste offizielle Gelegenheit unserer Story.
Das hat also funktioniert sozusagen, der Notruf über Amateur-Funk, interessant. Die hatten bestimmt doch auch den Moment, die Risslein...
Ja, wir hatten auch noch eine amerikanische Station, aber da mussten wir blind funken, weil damals waren große Störungen auch noch auf der Leitung zwischen diesen amerikanischen Bodenstationen. Die waren noch nicht entsprechend umgerüstet, um auf die irisische Frequenz auch zu lauschen. Da haben wir es natürlich auch hingefunkt. Aber wer jetzt zuerst das Rennen gewonnen gemacht hat, ich glaube, das war ein totes Rennen. Moskau Bescheid, so zu sagen.
Aber jetzt war das Gift in der Luft und noch zwei Stunden Sauerstoff aus dem Notversorgungssystem.
Das haben wir dann mit den Anbortsystemen schaffen müssen, diese Luft in der Zeit so zu... Also für uns so zu reinigen, dass wir das Experiment wagen konnten, die Gasmasken abzunehmen. Es war relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass da viel CO entstanden war. CO konnte man nicht messen, weil das war ja sauerstoffreiche Flamme. CO ist ja eher nur Verkokelung.
Also Prolmonoxid sehr giftig auf jeden Fall.
Und das wäre die größte Gefahr gewesen. Über Schwebeteilchen, da kann man natürlich nichts sagen, Asbest oder was weiß ich, was in der Lunge dann auftrifft. Da hätten wir mit solchen Chirurgenmasken dann natürlich ein bisschen Vorsorge treffen können. CO2 konnten wir ablesen, das war nicht wesentlich erhöht. Also von daher gab es dann auch wenig Anlass zur Sorge. Und die restlichen Bestandteile, Nitrose, Gase etc., das musste man in Kauf nehmen. Das hätte man nach Geruch oder auch entscheiden müssen. Bei denen, die aktiv an der Feuerbekämpfung dann beteiligt waren, ging natürlich die Luft aus der Gasmaske zuerst aus. Die haben ihre Gasmaske abgelegt. Wir haben uns dann immer in Paaren nur durch die Station bewegt, alles abgewaschen, gesaugt und geguckt. Hat jemand Anzeichen von Vergiftung? Blaue Finger, blaue Lippen, irgendwelche Ohnmachtserscheinungen. Die Vereinbarung war, wenn das auftritt, kehren die beiden Besatzungen in ihren jeweiligen Soyuzkapseln zurück. Drei und drei auf die Soyuzkapseln aufgeteilt. Das war Gott sei Dank nicht der Fall. Als wir uns dann um sechs da bei der Bodenstation meldeten, war eigentlich klar, dass wir weitermachen wollten. Die Raumstation war also nicht in einer tödlichen Situation, sondern eben eingeschränkt weitermachen konnten. Wir haben natürlich dieses System verloren, was uns die Zusatzsauerstoff gab. Das heißt, Sport war für die nächste Zeit gestrichen. Sport ist ja nun intensiver Sauerstoffverbrauch. Wir haben immer geguckt, dass wir den CO2-Gehalt der Luft entsprechend einrichten, aber das war sicherlich auch schwierig. Das war so ein bisschen der Anfang vom Ende, eigentlich auch der stolzen Mir-Zeit. Danach häuften sich ja die Fehler. Der Computer setzte aus, die Mir verlor zunehmend Orientierung und musste mühsam von der Besatzung wieder eingerichtet werden. Die Elektroversorgung und eins der Vorzeigemodule schlug leck in der Folge 1997 durch diesen Prozess. Da war ich natürlich nicht mehr an Bord. Das war jetzt einfach nur die Folge von Ereignissen. Die Kühlleitungen leckten zunehmend. Die Kühlleitungen russischer Prägung haben also Diethylenglykol, das bekannte Kühler-Frostschutzmittel drin, um einfach den thermischen Austausch zu befördern. Das trat aus, gab Juckreiz in den Augen. Beim Inhalieren ist es auch nicht sehr gesund. Da zeigte die MIR dann schon entscheidende Einschränkungen. Das hat letztlich dazu geführt, dass man sie dann aus dem Orbit genommen hat.
Irgendwann war dann klar, dass man aber mit den Raumstationen weitermachen wollte, auch wenn die MIR schon so langsam vor sich hin bröckelte. Was führte dann letzten Endes zum Durchbruch für die Entscheidung zur ISS?
Das war jetzt nicht ein Hingucken auf die MIR. Und wir müssen anfangen, die neue Raumstation zu planen, wenn die MIR so in die späten Jahre kommt. Das war eine politische Entscheidung, das unabhängig von den Russen aufzusetzen. Und die überzeugende Erfahrung der MIR-Raumstation und auch die Erkenntnis, dass man es nicht alleine schafft, das hat dazu geführt, dass man die Russen eingeladen hat. Man ist gut, also die Amerikaner hat die Russen eingeladen haben, bei der Raumstation mitzumachen und nach Langwierigen verfahren. Auch im Vertragsverfahren ist diese Kooperation erweitert worden. Und mit den entsprechenden Regierungsverträgen verankert, entstand dann die internationale Raumstation, die aus russischen und amerikanischen Elementen entstand. Und wo jeder Partner aber auch ein Element beisteuern musste, wenn diese Partnerschaft bekräftigt werden sollte. Also Japan, Europa, Kanada haben jeweils ein Element beigesteuert, wobei Kanada kein Druckmodul hochgeschickt hat, sondern diesen Roboterarm. Und die Russen und die Amerikaner haben im Wesentlichen dann die Vorgaben gegeben, wann und wie die Aufbausequenz stattfindet.
Wofür braucht man denn nun eigentlich die Raumstation, außer diesen Traum da zu entwickeln? Man stellt sich immer vor, die Astronauten kommen jetzt da hoch und dann machen sie schön viel Sport und so. Das klingt immer so ein bisschen, als wäre das jetzt so ein reiner Abenteuerurlaub für Astronauten. Das ist es natürlich nicht, sondern es gibt natürlich ein technisches Interesse, ein wissenschaftliches und sicherlich auch ein wirtschaftliches Interesse. Worin besteht das konkret? Wofür wird die Raumstation wirklich benötigt? Wofür wird sie eingesetzt?
Wenn ich die Geschichte, die Werbegeschichte der Raumstation nochmal neu schreiben könnte, würde ich wesentliche Korrekturen anbringen. Ich glaube, dass der Aspekt in internationaler Partnerschaft einer Raumstation zu konzipieren, die Teile zu bauen, die Teile im All zusammen zu bauen und dann auch überzeugend zu betreiben, völlig unterschätzt wurde gegenüber dem Aspekt, der immer verkauft wurde, ab da können wir dann wunderbare Materialien im All erzeugen. Wir können Riesenkristalle züchten, wir können jeden Tag aufs Neue Spin-offs, das ist dann der Ausdruck, der dann immer fällt, auf die Erde zurück transportieren, die aus dieser Raumfahrt dann ein Profitgeschäft machen. Gott sei Dank haben die Gründungsväter der Raumstation nicht so gedacht, als sie sich mit diesen Verträgen dann beschäftigt haben und in der Folge sind auch die Gelder bewilligt worden, um die Raumstation ins All zu bringen. Das war immer ein bisschen mühsam. Da gab es immer Diskussionen, aber letztlich hat dann, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, die Abstimmung ergeben, dass man die Raumstation weiter betreiben. So haben wir sie heute. Das ist schon etwas. Das ist schon allein diese Raumstation wert, dass wir da zeigen, dass man diese Struktur in wirklich gemeinschaftlicher Zusammenarbeit bauen kann, dass man auch jetzt schon inzwischen zwei, drei Generationen von Leuten damit begeistern kann, Detailprobleme der Raumstation zu lösen und auch am Ball zu bleiben, wenn es schwierig wird. Denn diese Leute bleiben ja dann letztlich nicht im Raumstationsprojekt, sondern gehen auch woanders hin und bringen diesen Geist mit, den sie in den Projekten kennengelernt haben. Ich sehe das hier bei unseren Flight-Controllern. Das sind junge Leute, die ihre Nachtstunden gerne dransetzen, um an diesem Projekt mitzuarbeiten, für die das das Höchste ist, von dem Astronauten, der oben war, zu hören. Also zusammen haben wir da einiges geschafft. Und das ist eine tolle Sache gewesen. Mit diesem Geist gehen sie in ihre nächsten Projekte und machen da auch gute Arbeit. Dass die Raumstation gebaut wurde, um letztendlich nicht Quiz-Shows im All zu unterstützen, sondern Wissenschaft, das ist der Effekt natürlich, wenn man eine solche Infrastruktur aufbaut, sollte man auch ein Konzept haben, sie vernünftig zu nutzen. Aber es ist nicht das Einzige. Und das ist ganz wichtig, dass man nicht in diese Rechtfertigungsklemme kommt, dass man sagt, wo sind denn jetzt heute eure neuen Metalle aus dem All? Wo sind denn die Weltraum-Ergebnisse, die in Medizin, in Biologie, in Materialwissenschaften, die Dollars und die Euros, die wir dafür verwendet haben, zurückzahlen? Das ist keine Aktiengesellschaft. Wir sind nicht profitorientiert. Wir sind eine Möglichkeit. Die USA hat das jetzt anerkannt, indem die Raumstation ein nationales Forschungslaboratorium ist, genauso wie Beschleuniger, also kernteilchen Forschungsanlagen, genauso wie große Anlagen, die für die Fusionsforschung gebaut wurden. Oder wie große Windkanäle, die neue aerodynamische Fortschritte bei Flugzeugen ermöglichen. So muss man diese Raumstation sehen. Sie ist eine Möglichkeit, sie ist ein Angebot. Sie hat jetzt kein Programm, wo wir sagen, in fünf Jahren haben wir alle Versuche durch. Und dann ziehen wir Bilanz und sagen, ist nichts rausgekommen, war eine Geldverschwendung. Das ist einfach ein Ansporn, diese Raumstation jetzt auch bestmöglich zu nutzen. So, nach dieser Vorrede kommen wir dann in den Teil, was wird da oben gemacht? Da oben wird in lang anhaltender und mit der Möglichkeit lang dauernd zu forschen, werden die Disziplinen behandelt, die in besonderer Weise auf der Erde unter der Gravitation, mit Gravitation zu tun haben oder deren Effekte gravitationsabhängig sind. Die Physik geht diesen Weg, dass man, wenn man ein Experiment unternimmt, die einzelnen Einflüsse auf dieses Experiment versucht zu separieren und zu kontrollieren. Umgebungseinflüsse, Strahlungseinflüsse, alles das, was bis auf Zufallsexperimente, bei der Entdeckung der Röntgenstrahlen zum Beispiel, da hat man diesen Strahlungseinfluss nicht kontrolliert. Und siehe da, die Strahlung auf diese Platten war so, dass man einen Effekt gesehen hat. Aber normalerweise, wenn man ein kontrolliertes Experiment hat, dann möchte man eins nach dem anderen anschalten. Das Einzige, was wir nicht anschalten können und abschalten können hier unten auf der Erde, ist die Gravitation. Dazu müssen wir ins All gehen. Wir machen Vorversuche auf Parabelflugzeugen. Da gibt es dann 25 Sekunden Schwerelosigkeit. Wir können Falltürme einsetzen, da sind es vielleicht 10 Sekunden. Wir können unbemannte Forschungskapseln mit Raketen in die höhere Atmosphäre bringen und wieder zurückfallen lassen. Dann sind es vielleicht in der Gegend von 10 Minuten Schwerelosigkeit. Aber die langwierige Entwicklung, auch wenn man an ein biologisches System denkt, das Vererben von Stämmen oder Entwicklung von mehreren Generationen, das können wir nur in der Raumstation sehen. Dafür haben wir diese Gelegenheit geschaffen. Dafür bieten wir diese Raumstation an. Diese Experimente werden ja auch gemacht, aber nicht unter dem Druck, der vielleicht bei einer Forschungsabteilung einer Firma da ist, in zwei Jahren Ergebnisse zu zeigen, die die Forschungsgelder und die Subventionen wieder reinspielen.
Was wären denn Beispiele für solche Experimente?
Nehmen wir mal die einzelnen Möglichkeiten, mit dem Faktor, Gravitation ja oder nein, zu spielen. Erstens muss man vorausschicken, da oben herrscht Gravitation. Die herrscht ja auch im Mond.
Es gibt nicht keine, aber sie wirkt sich nicht aus.
Durch die Art des Orbits sind wir in einem freien Fall, in einem ständigen freien Fall um die Erde. Das bewirkt, dass man die Schwerkraftwirkung aufgehoben hat durch andere Kräfte und sozusagen kräftefrei. Man findet sich im freien Fall.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Der freie Fall ist ja bekannt. Das hat man ja schon, wenn man vom Trampolin aus abspringt, in dem Moment, wo man das Trampolin verlässt, wo das Trampolin also keine Kraft mehr auf die Füße ausübt, ist man im freien Fall. Nur man hat eine Anfangsgeschwindigkeit, die einen noch gegen die Erdschwere so ein bisschen nach oben transportiert, bevor dann sichtbar auch der Fall einsetzt. Aber der Physiker spricht also vom freien Fall, dann, wenn keine Kräfteeinwirkung mehr auf den Körper ist und er diesen herrschenden Kräften eben nachgibt. Das ist immer auch durch eine Beschleunigung ausgedrückt. Im Fall des Earth Orbits ist die Beschleunigung eine Winkelbeschleunigung. Wir werden also immer wieder in einer Kreisbahn gezwungen, obwohl wir mit einer sehr hohen Anfangsgeschwindigkeit eigentlich tangential, also in gerader Richtung wegfliegen wollen, werden wir immer wieder auf eine Kreisbahn gezwungen. Das ist die Erdgravitation. Aber durch diese hohe Anfangsgeschwindigkeit, das sind 7,5 Kilometer pro Sekunde, fallen wir nie auf die Erde, sondern immer an der Erde vorbei, was also den freien Fall sozusagen ausmacht. Diese Komponente wären wir auch nicht los. Wir können nicht einfach uns umdrehen und zur Erdoberfläche zurücksteuern. Dazu müssten wir 7,5 Kilometer pro Sekunde energielos werden, um auf die Erde dann zuzufallen. Und das macht uns die Rakete. Deshalb ist die Rakete so, wie sie ist, mit viel Feuer und Rauch und Energie. Und das pumpt die alles in diese paar 100 Kilogramm, die dann oben im All ankommen. Diese Energie werden wir nicht so einfach los. Aber die Erde ist natürlich auch massiv und zieht uns dann in diese Kreisbahn. In der Kreisbahn ist man also kräftefrei. Das heißt, wir können die Gravitation ausschalten. Wir haben ganz interessante Effekte gesehen, die wir nie mit Gravitation in Verbindung gebracht hätten auf der Erde, gerade im Bereich der Lebenswissenschaften. Da entdecken wir immer mehr Sachen, die offensichtlich auf der Erde anders ablaufen als im All. Wenn wir dann versuchen einzelne Effekte zu isolieren, ist es natürlich eine wunderbare Gelegenheit, hier mal jetzt Gravitation zu isolieren, die Gravitationseffekte. Beispiel? Verbrennung. Wenn wir also einen Verbrennungsvorgang beobachten, dann wird das unweigerlich zu einer Konvektionsströmung kommen. Das heißt, das Warme steigt hoch und das kalte Ström von unten nach. Das ist einfach Charakteristikum hier auf der Erde, dass warmes Gas nach oben steigt und sich über dem dichteren kalten Gas dann lagert. Haben wir nicht im Weltall. Wir können also in aller Ruhe Effekte beobachten, die unten auf der Erde viel hektischer verlaufen, zum Beispiel Diffusionseffekte innerhalb der Umgebung dieser Verbrennung. Nun bin ich ja durch Verbrennung geschlagen, aber das war eine andere Verbrennung, die wir als Brander hatten. Wir lassen also eine Flamme im All brennen oder setzen den Verbrennungsvorgang in Gang und sehen dann, dass dieser Effekt, der auf der Erde bewirkt, dass immer frisches, sauerstoffreiches Gas von unten nachströmt, die Flamme also sehr lebhaft am Leben erhält und das verbrauchte, sauerstoffarme Gas, weil Wärmer nach oben weggeht, dass das eben nicht der Fall ist. Die Flammen sind kümmerlich, die sind schwach, die sind kugelförmig, nicht so eine typische Kerzenflammenform. Und in diesem Austausch zwischen den Gasen der Umgebung und dem Flammenkörper selbst passieren also Dinge, die wir untersuchen können, die wir auf der Erde wegen der allgemeinen Dynamik der Konvektion eben nicht sehen. Wenn wir da nur Prozenteffekte erreichen, dass wir also eine Verbrennung effektiver gestalten, dass wir eine Verbrennung besser steuern können, ist das bei den Milliarden Verbrennungsvorgängen, die auf der Welt also ablaufen, natürlich ein Riesenfortschritt an Erkenntnis. Die viel zitierten Kristalle, da wird es sicherlich auch in irrtischen Laboratorien schon Möglichkeiten geben, große Protein-Kristalle oder andere organische Kristalle so zu züchten, dass man die der Analyse zuführen kann. Aber im Weltall ist das das Gegebene. Da braucht man sich gar nicht viel Gedanken zu machen, außer einen ziemlich störungsfreien Ort zu finden, an dem diese Kristalle aus einer gesättigten Lösung dann entstehen. Diese Einzelstücke, das sind ja keine Massenfertigung, diese Einzelstücke werden auf die Erde gebracht, der analysiert und damit die Struktur des Proteins, der Moleküle, die dann den Kristall gebildet haben, dann entsprechend besser aufgeklärt. In der Medizin gibt es ein ganz interessantes Experiment, was ich angefangen habe, Jojo, bei meiner Mission, die war hauptsächlich medizinisch orientiert, und was zurzeit noch auf der Raumstation läuft. Der Effekt der Flüssigkeitsregulierung im Körper, der hat sehr viel mit Salz zu tun, für jedes Gramm Salz lagert der Körper auch eine bestimmte Menge Flüssigkeit ein, um die allgemeine Konzentration in den Körperflüssigkeiten konstant zu erhalten. Man hat immer gedacht, wenn man Salz zuführt, dann eine Tüte Chips oder sowas, dann wird der Körper im Laufe der Zeit dafür sorgen, dass entsprechende Mengen Flüssigkeit auch mit eingelagert werden, damit dieser Salzgehalt, bevor er dann abgebaut wird, auch für den Körper verträglich ist. Ein Effekt, den man bei mir entdeckt hat, ist, dass ich sehr viel mehr Salz durch einen sehr kontrollierten Nahrungszufuhr und Flüssigkeitszufuhr, ich habe alles protokolliert, alles wirklich nach Vorschrift gegessen, nicht Diät, also nicht wenig, sondern was ich aß, war absolut vorher getestet und wohl definiert. Dadurch hat man erreicht, dass man einen idealen Untergrund für Experimente hatte. Diese Experimente hat man dann als Provokation sozusagen auf meinen täglichen Nahrungsumsatz gegeben und hat festgestellt, dass ich sehr viel mehr Salz einlagere, als ich abgebe, aber nicht mit der entsprechenden Flüssigkeitseinlage auch. Was dazu führt, dass eigentlich wie ein Grundproblem auch für Patienten auf der Erde, die an Ödemen oder an ähnlichen Effekten fehlgegangener Flüssigkeitseinlage arbeiten, dass wir diese Probleme überhaupt nicht richtig verstanden haben. Dass wir offensichtlich mit der Regel, wenn Salz dann auf Flüssigkeit nicht zu rangekommen, sondern irgendwelche Effekte im Körper auch noch triggern, die wir bis jetzt nicht kennen. Und wo hat man das Salz gefunden? Man hat es dann dankenswerterweise rattenbiopsiert, nicht mich, und hat es im Subkutane-Gewebe gefunden. Es gibt also einen Nicht-Mechanismus unten im Gewebe, unterhalb der Haut, in Unterhautschichten, also Salzeinlagern, den man überhaupt nicht kennengelernt hat. Der aber gerade für die Salzhaushaltregulierung der Menschen sehr entscheidend einen Anteil haben könnte. Man hat zwar immer an der Nionfunktion gedreht oder man hat sonst wie den Stoffwechsel von Salz versucht zu regulieren, aber an die Haut hat eigentlich keiner gedacht. Das sind Effekte, die man natürlich erst sieht, wenn der Körper in dieser extremen Situation, in dieser ungewohnten Umgebung mit einem ganz anderen Mechanismus auf einmal rausrückt, der uns eingebaut ist, den der Körper ja nicht programmiert haben kann durch Jahrtausende Evolutionen, aber der einfach ein unbekanntes Reservoir, ein unbekanntes Potenzial des Körpers darstellt, dass erst durch diese Umgebung, durch die Weltraumumgebung in diesem Fall zugänglich der Forschung gemacht wird. In der Biologie haben wir sehr viele phenomenologische Experimente, d.h. wir haben beobachtet, was machen denn biologische Systeme unter Schwerelosigkeitsbedingungen. Wir haben aus dem unsere Schlüsse gezogen, sind jetzt wirklich auf das Zellniveau runter, dass wir versuchen, also den Stimulus auf die Zelle zu definieren, den die Schwerelosigkeit darstellt, warum die Zelle sich anders verhält als unter schwere Bedingungen. Das ist nicht offensichtlich. Das ist etwas, wo man also auch sehr viel über die Zelle lernen kann, wenn wir an immunologische Reaktionen denken, also Abwehrreaktionen des Körpers, die an Schwerelosigkeit signifikant reduziert sind. Wir alle liefen also mit sehr viel mehr Jod bepinselten Kratzern und ähnlichem rum in der Raumstation, als wir das hier auf der Erde tun würden, weil einfach jeder Kratzer das Potential bot, bei geschwächter Immunabwehr sich zu einer Entzündung zu entwickeln etc. Das sind also Anfangs Beobachtungen, dann gibt es eine Hypothese und wir sind jetzt in einer Phase, gerade auch in der Medizin, die sehr hypothesengesteuert, ganz gezielt im Weltall versucht, Effekten nachzugehen, die wir in dieser Beobachtungsphase über Jahre hinweg gewonnen haben.
Was diese ganzen biologischen Experimente betrifft, kann man ja eigentlich auch feststellen, dass so die Astronauten in der Raumstation eigentlich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes eigentlich die Versuchskaninchen sind. Also dass ein Großteil der Experimente auch tatsächlich am Mann oder der Frau ausgeführt wird. Und es jetzt nicht nur um Experimente geht, die in Computern und auf speziellen Laborträgern stattfinden. Ist das richtig?
Ja, das ist richtig. Es ist jetzt ein Thema, es ist nicht das ausschließlich Thema. Und vor allen Dingen ist es nicht ein Thema, weil wir erforschen wollen, wie man lang und länger im All lebt. Das ist ein Abfallprodukt oder ein Nebenprodukt, würde ich mal sagen, der Sache, dass wir natürlich auch lernen, wie man einen Menschen gesund erhält unter diesen Bedingungen im All. Wenn das Gegenargument ist, dann schickt keine hoch, dann braucht er das auch nicht zu lernen. Das ist aber nicht die Sache, sondern die anderen Effekte sind so lehrreich, dass wir auch dann in der Lage sind, einen Menschen im All unter dem Ding der Schwerlosigkeit gesund zu erhalten. Sprich, Knochenabbau, Osteoporose, die im All durch die Fehlbelastung des Knochengrußes sehr viel schneller vor sich geht, die Umlagerung von Muskeln. Das Rekrutieren von bestimmten Bewegungsformen ist im All komplett anders als auf der Erde, weil die nicht die schnellen Reaktionen überwiegen, sondern die langsamen. Das heißt, wir lernen auch sehr viel über die Nerven, die Muskeln ansprechen und rekrutieren. Das sind auch Elemente gewesen, die schon in meiner Mission akut waren, aber die jetzt aktuell waren, aber die mehr und mehr auch gezielt mit Langzeitforschung dann in Angriff genommen werden können. Zumal die Zahl der Testprobande natürlich sehr gering ist. Das muss man sagen. Wenn man es an einem sieht, heißt das nicht, dass das ein Standard-Effekt ist. Man muss schon nachlegen, man muss über die Zeit dann auch mehr Besatzungsmitglieder testen und versuchen, aus der Statistik dann den Zufallseffekt rauszufiltern und den systemischen Effekt dann zu sehen. Das ist die Tätigkeit, die wir da momentan machen. Das sind die klassischen Gebiete, zu denen aber, das sollte man nicht vergessen, jetzt nur eins dazu kommt, das ist die Grundlagenphysik. Wir haben sehr interessante Versuche gemacht, im Hinblick auf flüchtige Strukturen. Dazu werden kleine Staubteilchen, die sind natürlich künstlich hergestellt und normiert in der Größe Staubteilchen, in einem elektrisch aufgeladenen Gas beobachtet, die eine Art Kristallstruktur in diesem Gas einnehmen. Und wenn man mal sieht, was bei Flüssig-Kristallbildschirmen und bei anderen Strukturversuchen auf der Erde momentan aktuell ist, ist das also ein Riesenpotenzial, auch mit Gasen und mit geleiteter Anordnung von Strukturen in Gasen vielleicht da Fortschritte zu machen. Und der Schwerelosigkeit entfällt also dieser Effekt, dass diese Kügelchen alle nach unten wollen und alle sich am Boden versammeln, sondern die bleiben einfach da, wo sie sind. Und das kann man untersuchen. Und eins der Highlights natürlich, da warten wir auf den Start dieses Jahr, das ist das Alpha Magnetic Spectrometer, eine Entwicklung, die also durch einen großen Magnetring im Weltall sehr exotische Teilchen rausfiltern soll aus dem Strom von Teilchen, der natürlich die Erde umgibt. Teilchen, die nie auf der Erde ankommen würden, weil sie vorher schon mit Reaktionspartnern und mit entsprechenden Dingen abgelenkt würden, die aber in diesem Spektrometer sich verfangen und eventuell auch physikalische Theorien verifizieren, helfen oder auch falsifizieren.
Kommen wir noch einmal kurz zur ISS. Im Prinzip sind wir ja schon längst da. Die ISS wurde über mehrere Jahre aufgebaut und folgt im Prinzip derselben Bauweise und Bauidee der Mir. Das heißt, es gab ein Kernmodul, an das dann eben über entsprechende Modulanschlüsse in zunehmendem Maße weitere Module gemacht wurden, die dann eben von unterschiedlichen Partnern, also einerseits von den Russen, also Roskosmos ist das, der NASA, der ESA, JAXA, den Japanern und den kanadischen Space Agency, CSA, herangebaut wurden. Und ist denn die ISS jetzt schon fertig oder wird noch weiter angebaut werden?
Die ISS ist nominell fertig. Das heißt, die Konfiguration ist erreicht, auf die sich diese Heads of Agencies, also die Leiter der Agenturen, die stellvertretend für die Länder diese Aufgabe wahrgenommen haben, geeinigt haben. Das ist auf dem Papier dann der Zustand, ab dem auch die zur Verfügung stehenden Ressourcen berechnet werden. Also die Möglichkeiten, die jeder Partner mit der Raumstation hat, das richtet sich nämlich nach der Prozentzahl des Beitrages, den die Partner geleistet haben. Die grundsätzliche Aufteilung ist, USA und Russland haben je 50 Prozent der Raumstation. USA unterhält aber dann über sogenannte Memoranda auf Understanding, also gegenseitige Abkommen, mit den Partnern ESA, JAXA und CSA Unterteilungen, von denen wir profitieren. Die ESA ist mit etwa 8,5 Prozent der USA beteiligt. Das erstreckt sich auf alle Ressourcen, ob es elektrische Leistungen ist, ob es die Möglichkeit ist, etwas an Bord unterzubringen ist, oder auch in den Stunden, die ein ESA-Crew-Mensch an Bord der Raumstation verbringen kann. Das regelt sich alles aus diesen Prozent-Aufteilungen. Und so sind diese Besatzungen, die zur Raumstation gehen, typischerweise so besetzt, dass der Russe die Soyuz fliegt und den russischen 50-Prozent-Anteil demonstriert. Und dann auf den Nebensitzen entweder mal ein Europäer, ein Amerikaner, ein Japaner oder ein Kanadier sitzt oder auch noch ein zweiter Russe, je nachdem, dass es dann auf zwei Jahre gemittelt oder so ungefähr auf diese Anteile hinauskommt.
Und was machen jetzt die einzelnen Module der ISS? Also welche Module gibt es konkret?
Die Hauptlebensfunktionen wurden von den Russen gestellt. Inzwischen haben die Amerikaner durch Zusatzmodule auch schon große Teile der Lufterneuerung übernommen. Aber die Besatzung traditionellerweise wird noch immer den Basisblock für die allgemeinen Aktivitäten mit dem großen Tisch und so weiter vorziehen. Es gibt zwar jetzt auch schon die Möglichkeit, Essen in anderen Modulen zu erwerben und auch erwärmen. Es gibt auch die Hygiene-Abteilung, gibt es jetzt in mehreren Modulen, ursprünglich nur im Russischen, jetzt aber auch zunehmend in den amerikanischen. Die Amerikaner versorgen die Station hauptsächlich mit Strom. Das sind also die großen, auf dem Gerüst eingebauten vier Solar-Panele, die leisten 30 Kilowatt pro Stück. Das ist eine enorme Leistung, die also dann den Laboratorien zur Verfügung steht und auch zum Teil in den russischen Teil der Raumstation übergeleitet werden. Die Kommunikation ist auch amerikanisch über die Satelliten, die in geostationären Erdorbit die Stationen immer im Blick haben. Über die wird also das Breitbandier Kommunikationsgeschäft abgewickelt, was Video beinhaltet, was die Möglichkeit hat, bei Inhalt für die Besatzung Telefonate zu führen. Und die Russen schalten gelegentlich noch ihre UKW-Sender an über Russland, bedienen sich aber auch schon jetzt zum großen Teil einfach der Crew-Kommunikation wegen und dem Abgleich der verschiedenen Informationsstände. Bedienen sie sich dieses amerikanischen Systems. Die Russen sind teilweise für die Lage-Regelung verantwortlich, in dem Moment, wo die amerikanischen Kreisel in die Sättigung gehen, die normalerweise die Feinjustierung der Raumstation übernehmen. Was heißt das, dass sie in die Sättigung gehen? Kreiselsysteme nutzen eben den eben schon beschriebenen Inertialeffekt aus. Das heißt, wenn sie einmal in Bewegung gesetzt sind, lässt sich der Drehimpuls dieser Kreisel nur ganz schwer verändern. Das ist so ein Schulversuch, dass man so ein Speichenrad in die Hand bekommt. Und das wird dann aufgesponnen. Und wenn man dann versucht, das Speichenrad aus der ursprünglichen Lage zu bringen, dann merkt man, das wehrt sich irgendwie. Das gibt so Ausweicheffekte und das macht man sich in Krafträdern, in Kreiselrädern macht man sich das zu Nutze. Die sind jetzt nicht so toll massiv, aber sie werden auf sehr hohe Umdrehungen gebracht. Das ist egal, was man von beiden maximiert. Und damit sind die raumstabil. Und an denen kann sich die Raumstation sozusagen abstoßen, wenn kleinere Korrekturen der Raumstation sind. Das sind ja 450 Tonnen, nicht? Und dann so ein entsprechendes Rad. Das ist schon eine Leistung, diese raumstabilen Geräte dann in Betrieb zu halten und dadurch die Feinsteuerung der Raumstation zu ermöglichen.
Das heißt, die Feinsteuerung funktioniert durch ein Abstoßen von Kreiseln. Da werden keine Raketen gezündet. Sondern es ist ein rein mechanischer Vorgang im Prinzip. Aber wie stößt man sich an diesem Kreisel ab?
Der Kreisel ist raumstabil durch die hohen Drehungszahl und die Masse, die da bewegt ist, hat sich das System etabliert im Raum. Und hat gar keine Lust, seine Lage da zu verändern. Wenn man dann von außen eine Verbindung schafft, die Raumstation also kurzzeitig mit dem Kreisel verbindet und auslenkt, dann überträgt sich ein bisschen was von dieser Energie des Kreiselrades auf die Raumstation. Die Kreiselräder werden natürlich elektrisch betrieben. Das heißt, da kann man dauernd Energie nachschieben. Aber die gehen dann irgendwann in die Sättigung. Wenn die Raumstation sich lang genug in einer Richtung davon abgedrückt hat, dann ist es irgendwo ungünstig von der Lage dieses Drehimpulses.
Dann kann man sozusagen nicht noch mehr Kraft herausziehen.
So, das ist jetzt zu dieser Punktung der eine Satz. Da muss man einfach wieder an 90 Grad das Ganze zurückdrehen, das System, und das machen dann tatsächlich Triebwerke im russischen Teil oder bei den angekoppelten Raumfahrzeugen. Die dann auch eine Rolle spielen, dass die, je nachdem was günstig ist, dass die die Raumstation gegenüber diesen Kreiselrädern wieder in eine effektive Lage bringen.
Und das ist auch so eine Technik, die ist jetzt schon längere Zeit. Wie ist es bei den Raumstationen so?
Gleich, im Betrieb haben wir diesen Kreiselräder. Da hat man dann die ganze Steuerung darauf umgestellt.
Das ist noch so eine Salyut-Technik schon, oder?
Ja, das gab es auch schon an der Salyut, aber die amerikanischen Kreiselräder sind schon sehr viel effektiver als die Mürre hatte und auch die Salyut. Das spart Treibstoff und Treibstoff müsste ja hochgebracht werden, was also wieder Transport bedeutet. Treibstoff wird verbraucht, während diese Kreiselräder nur Strom hauen.
Und den kriegt man dann aus der Sonne.
Das sind die Dinge, die die Russen machen. Außerdem liefern sie natürlich die Besatzungen, also die Soyuz. Das ist ein schwerer Brocken, den die Amerikaner nach Ende dieses Shuttle-Programms zu schlucken hatten, dass sie jetzt Sitze im Soyuz kaufen müssen, dass sie also ihre Leute ausschließlich mit einem russischen System ins All bekommen. Das ist sicherlich auch Gegenstand der politischen Debatte in den USA. Das liefern die Russen. Die Russen liefern über die Progress auch dann Fracht zur Raumstation. Das sind für die Leiden ununterscheidbar von Soyuz kapseln, aber es sind unbemannte Frachtkapseln, die in anderen Sätzen auch. Entsprechend übernehmen wir aber auch diese Aufgaben, nämlich mit dem ATV leisten wir genau das. Wir sind in der Lage, die Raumstation auf höhere Orbits wieder zu bringen. Die fällt mit der Zeit und mit ein bisschen Atmosphärenreibung und anderen Effekten. Sie fällt also nach und nach auf tiefe Orbits. Das ist nicht gut, das wird dann wieder hochgehoben. Das macht das ATV, das ATV bringt Fracht. Damit leisten wir keine finanziellen Beiträge zur Internationalen Raumstation, sondern wir leisten Sachbeiträge zur Internationalen Raumstation, die im Rahmen unseres 8,5% Anteils dann die Kosten gegenhalten. Das ist eigentlich der angenehme Effekt von unserem ATV. Erstens war es natürlich eine Riesenentwicklung für die europäische Raumfahrtindustrie und zweitens hilft das ATV uns, die Kosten der Raumstationen gegenzuhalten.
Vielleicht nochmal zurück zu den Modulen, einfach mal, dass die Struktur klar ist. Also es gibt so diese Kernmodule der Amerikaner. Welche sind das jetzt? Was ist das Kernmodul?
Gehen wir mal der Aufbaureihenfolge, die wichtigsten Aufbaureihenfolge nach. Das erste Modul, was ins All gebracht wurde, war eine Kopplung zwischen einem amerikanischen Kopplungsknoten, dem allerersten Verbindungsstück, wo sich dann das amerikanische Segment dran entfaltete, und einem Last- und Logistikteil der Russen, FGB, genannt. Dieses FGB hat eine sehr traurige Aufbaugeschichte, ist sehr lange nicht fertig geworden, bis die Amerikaner dann mit Geld nachgeholfen haben. Und so zählt es eigentlich als amerikanisches Modul, obwohl es russischer Bauacht ist. Die erste Besatzung konnte dann kommen, als man den Basisblock der Raumstation dazu addiert, also ein russisches Modul, auch unbemannt gestartet und autonom an die Raumstation herangeführt. Das ist genau vom Modell her dasselbe, wie wir den Basisblock der Mirra kennengelernt haben. Also einen Teil mit Lebenserhaltungsgeräten, mit Versorgung, mit heißem und kaltem Wasser.
Hat der auch noch so einen fancy Namen?
Fancy Name? Zarya ist der FGB. Zarya. Mal gucken, ob ich die noch alles zusammenkriege. Also Unity ist der Koppelungsknoten der Amerikaner. Das war dann auch schon maßgebend oder zielsetzend der Name. Zarya ist der FGB, der erste Funktional- und Kargoblock. Dann das zweite ist Zvezda. Das ist also die MIR-Nachbau des Basisblocks. Und dann haben die Russen noch weitere Schleusen-Module an Zarya reingesetzt, an FGB. Es gibt jetzt ein Multifunktionsmodul, wo auch eine Wissenschaft gemacht wird. Immer wieder auch neue Docking-Möglichkeiten für russische Raumfahrzeuge. Unser ATV wird also an Zarya anlegen. In radialer Richtung an den Wohnblock herangeführt und bis Juni dann verkoppelt. Auf der amerikanischen Seite war das nächste, dass man sich um den Ausbau der Kommunikation und der Elektroversorgung gekümmert hat. Das war mit einem anfänglichen Gerüst-Element gewährleistet, das sogenannte Z-Element. Und dann hat man sich dran gegeben, als das dann fertig war, das erste Labor hochzuschießen. Das ist also Destiny, das ist das amerikanische Labor, was in der Achse der Raumstation ziemlich nah am Schwerpunkt liegt, an derzeitigen Schwerpunkten. Damit natürlich in idealer Weise die Mikrogravitationsbedingungen erfüllt. Nur Objekte, die auch genau die Bahngleichung erfüllen, haben eigentlich Mikrogravitation. Alle, die so ein paar Meter weiter draußen sind, die merken dann schon leichte Abweichungen von der Mikrogravitation.
Was heißt das Mikrogravitation?
Mikrogravitation heißt, dass wir wirklich eine stabile, störungsfreie Schwerelosigkeit in dem Bereich von 10 hoch minus 6 g, also das, was auf der Erde uns zum Boden zieht, haben. Das ist Mikrogravitation. Von der Theorie her ist das nur da gewährleistet, wo auf der Schwerpunkt der Station ist, weil da die Orbitalkräfte sich eben aufheben. Das ist in der Nähe des amerikanischen Labormodul. Deshalb sind da auch alle feinsinnigen Geräte, die sehr viel von diesen Restbeschleunigungen spüren untergebracht, nämlich die materialwissenschaftlichen Geräte und andere.
Und wenn man jetzt ein paar Meter weiter rausgeht, dann ist schon alles anders?
Dann hat man vielleicht nur noch 10 hoch minus 5 g. Das ist also dann nicht mehr so störungsfrei garantiert wie in der Mitte. Ist für lebenswissenschaftliche Experimente oder biologische Experimente unter Mikrogravitation überhaupt nicht von Belang? Weil die Schwellen, die lebende Organismen für Beschleunigungen haben, natürlich sehr viel höher liegen. Deshalb macht man in den Außenbezirken der Raumstation eher diese lebenswissenschaftlichen, biologischen und sonstigen Untersuchungen. Aber für physikalische Feinsteffekte würde man in die Nähe des Schwerpunkts gehen.
Da liegt Destiny. Destiny ist auch ein relativ großes Modul. Vielleicht sogar das größte, ich weiß nicht.
Also vom Volumen her, das größte ist das japanische. Und Destiny ist relativ ähnlich. Hat im Inneren eine Struktur, die es erlaubt, sogenannte Standartschränke, Standard-Pelodrecks, einzuschieben. Da ist dann die Schnittstelle, die Elektro-, die Wasser-, die Gasschnittstelle definiert. Man kriegt den ganzen Kasten integriert von unten geliefert. Da sind schon alle Experimente drin. Und schiebt diesen Kasten nur in die vorgesehene Leerstelle. Und alle Verbindungen kommen praktisch von selbst in Gang. Und auch die Datenverbindungen und ähnliches. Sodass man also genormte Schränke im Inneren der Raumstation nur im amerikanischen Teil, US Orbital Segment, gegeneinander austauschen kann. Die Russen haben dieser Philosophie nicht gefolgt. Die haben also mehr Einzelgeräte, die nicht einer Norm entspricht.
Also die Module sind schon so unterschiedlich, dass quasi jede Organisation sagen kann, wir machen das jetzt hier so. Hauptsache, es ist klar definiert, wie wir uns zum Rest der Station uns gegenüber verhalten. Aber innerhalb des Moduls herrschen eigene Regeln.
Nicht nur das, auch das Training ist darauf abgestellt, dass Astronauten, die unter dem amerikanischen Teil der Raumstation ausgebildet werden, auch nur da Operator oder Spezialisten Erfahrungen sammeln, sind für die gesamte Raumstation als Benutzer ausgebildet. Aber wenn es dann ans Reparieren, Austauschen oder Schwerearbeiten geht, nehmen die Amerikaner und die Europäer und Japaner Kanadier mit ihnen, neben die Arbeiten im amerikanischen Segment der Raumstation wahr, während die Russen das im russischen Segment machen. Dagegen kriegen die Russen keine Ausbildung im Columbus. Die würden also nie einen Luftfilter im Columbus tauschen müssen, weil sie eigentlich dieses Training nicht gehabt haben. Manettas Segregated Ops ist also eine Praktikabilitätsüberlegung, um die Trainingszeit im Rahmen zu halten. Widerspricht auch nicht dem internationalen Charakter der Raumstation.
Bleiben wir mal dabei alle Module, die relevant sind, auch aufzuzählen. Neben den Startmodulen der Russen und den Verbindungsknoten Unity hatten wir jetzt Destiny.
Ja, ab 2000 haben wir Destiny in der Besatzung gesehen. Das war schon vor Destiny. Das war der Basisblock, der dieses Vesta-Modul hochgeführt wurde. Mit Destiny konnten wir auch die ersten zielten Experimente, Experimenteinrichtungen in Betrieb nehmen. Dann haben wir warten müssen, bis der zweite Verbindungsknoten, Node 2, hoch war, bevor wir unser Columbus-Modul ernsthaft an den Start rollen konnten. Das war dann der Fall im Dezember 2007. Da ist dann Node 2 installiert worden. Mein ESA-Kollege Paolo Nespoli war mit am Bord, der jetzt auch am Bord der Raumstation für einen Langzeitflug.
Und fleißig fotografiert und twittert.
Das ist das Harmony-Modul?
Yes.
Als dieses Modul jetzt oben war, konnten wir mit Columbus auch wirklich loslegen. Was heißt loslegen? Dann war eine Chance, Columbus anzudocken. Das ist dann im Februar 2008 passiert. Danach haben die Japaner in zwei, drei Aufbauflügen ihr Modul auf die andere Seite von Harmony gebracht. Die sind seitlich angebracht, Columbus in Fahrtrichtung rechts und das japanische Modul in Fahrtrichtung links. Das japanische besteht hier wiederum aus drei Teilen. Das ist der eigentliche Laborteil, der nur scheinbar größer ist als Columbus. In Wirklichkeit ist es mehr Volumen. Aber von der Leistungsfähigkeit, von der Anzahl der Experimentierstellen, also diese Schränke, die da eingebaut werden können, ist es exakt wie Columbus.
Warum ist es dann so viel größer?
Ja, wir haben Columbus sehr kompakt gebaut, weil wir mit einem Shuttle-Flug voll integriert zur Raumstation fliegen wollten. Das ist einfach eine Frage des Geldes, das wir den Amerikanern dafür schulden.
Das heißt, die Japaner haben sich da etwas mehr Geld kosten lassen?
Ja, wir haben sich drei Shuttle-Flüge zur Ausstattung kosten lassen. Wenn wir aber das so tun, wenn wir ein so schweres Modul in den Shuttle bringen wollen, haben wir nur den hinteren Teil der Laderaumbuch zur Verfügung, weil die Gewichtsverteilung im Shuttle also sehr empfindlich auch für Schwerpunktlagen und Aerodynamik und so was ausgerechnet werden muss. Damit war es nicht möglich, ein so schweres, großes Modul in den Shuttle zu bringen, sondern wir mussten vom Schwerpunkt her nach hinten in den Shuttle. Und haben das Columbus dann sehr stark komprimiert. Und das sieht man auch, wenn man also den Bodendeckel hochhebt, wie viele Leitungen und elektrische Leitungen, Wasser, Kühlung, Luft, Zirkulation, alles Mögliche, auf engstem Raum untergebracht ist. In Columbus, das unterscheidet sich also in Columbus erheblich von den anderen Modulen. Das war Columbus. Mit Columbus fing unsere Partnerschaft an. Das war der ganz wichtige Moment. Wir wurden also zahlenpflichtig, was die Betriebskosten angeht. Vorher haben wir unsere Flüge über bilaterale Abkommen bezahlt oder in irgendeiner Form kompensiert mit Russland, mit USA. Ab jetzt waren wir Partner. Wir hatten also auch das Recht, Crew hochzuschicken. Der erste, der das ausgenutzt hat, war Leopold Eher. Der war ein paar Wochen oben, hat Columbus in der Anfangsphase begleitet. Aber der erste, der dann richtig einen Langzeitflug gemacht hat, war dann Frank De Winne, der auch gleich zum Commander der Raumstation befördert wurde. Auch das ist möglich unter der Partnerschaft, dass also die kleineren Partner auch mal das Commander übernehmen für die Zeit, wo die Besatzung da oben ist. Die Japaner haben dann ihr Modul ausgebaut und damit war eigentlich Assembly complete. Damit war die Vorgabe dieser Heads of Agencies, der Leiter der Raumfahrtorganisation, war erfüllt. Und dann das Berechnungssystem setzte ein und der Routine betrieb. Danach kam noch Note 3.
Das heißt jetzt Tranquility?
Tranquility, ja genau. Warum auch immer. Tranquilitat, das war die Apollo 11-Landestelle, so weit ich es nicht erinnere. Hier hat man mehr auf den Ausbau der Lebenserhaltungssysteme auch Wert gelegt. Das heißt in diesem Note 3 sind also eine zusätzliche Hygienestation, noch eine Toilette und auch Möglichkeiten für die Crew mit Schlafgelegenheit usw. Also sich etwas über die Raumstation noch besser zu verteilen.
Ist da nicht auch noch diese Aussichtskuppel da dran?
Kuppler war dann vor Note 3, noch eine Ergänzung oder nach. Die Kuppler ist in Europa gebaut, ist aber an die Amerikaner verkauft als Beitrag für Gegenleistung. Ist also ein Raum, der es ermöglicht, was in den anderen Modulen nur sehr schwer ist, einen Überblick über die Raumstation, rundum einen Überblick über die Raumstation zu gewinnen. Und mit der Ankunft der Kuppler wurde dort auch die robotische Arbeitsstation installiert. Das heißt, von da leiten die Astronauten, den großen Robot-Arm, den kanadischen Robot-Arm über die Raumstation. Das hat sich jetzt auch schon bewährt, als der japanische Transporter HTV, also mit HW Hotel, an die Raumstation herangeführt wurde. Im Gegensatz zu ATV kann er nicht allein navigieren, sondern er ist darauf angewiesen, dass ein Roboter-Arm ihn greift und an einen der Knoten heranführt, wo er dann luftig miteinander verbunden wird. Diese Arbeiten wurden schon aus der Cupola gemacht. Die Cupola ist natürlich sehr beliebt bei der Besatzung. Einfach a room with a view. Eine grandiose Aussicht eben.
Das ist auch so ein Klassiker eigentlich aus der Science-Fiction, dass man sowas natürlich in der Raumstation oder im Komfortzimmer auch hat.
Das haben sie alle übernommen, ob es jetzt Star Wars war oder 2001.
Dark Star fällt mir da ein, weil auch viel Zeit verbracht wird da oben. So, das heißt, muss man ein bisschen zusammenfassen, die Raumstation, klar, besteht aus Modulen. Das kann immer wieder angedockt werden. Im Prinzip bestehen auch noch Erweiterungsmöglichkeiten und es soll auch noch erweitert werden, auch wenn jetzt erstmal ein gewisser Basiszustand, der ursprünglich mal geplant war, weitgehend hergestellt wurde.
Die Russen möchten noch weiter ausbauen.
Und was fehlt noch? Also was hätte man noch gerne?
Also wir sind komplett, was unser Interesse an der Raumstation und unsere Sachen angeht. Wir können intern in Columbus natürlich noch ein paar Verbesserungen vornehmen. Da gibt es immer wieder Pläne, ob wir nicht unsere eigene Datenverbindung über den ESA-Satelliten-8-Demiss bewerkstelligen können. Das sind aber Sachen, die routinemäßig eigentlich den Politikern zur Entscheidung vorgelegt werden, wenn dann die nächste Phase zu finanzieren ist, ob es dann auch Geld für Neuentwicklungen gibt. Was uns natürlich auf den Nägeln brennt, ist das Problem des Rücktransports von Nutzlasten aus der Raumstation. Das ist mit dem Wegfall des Shuttles das große, große Problem und bis sich eine amerikanische Industrielösung soweit etabliert hat, das wird noch eine Zeit dauern. Da gibt es zwar Pläne und es gibt auch Entwicklungen, wo gerade in Amerika auch NASA angestoßen hat, dass die Industrie jetzt zunehmend diese Aufgaben übernimmt. Da nicht nur den Transport von Güter und Zuraumstationen in irgendeiner Form industriell zu gewährleisten, sondern auch den Rücktransport in Angriff zu nehmen. Aber diese Pläne helfen uns nicht, die Lücke zu schließen, die jetzt unmittelbar nach Wegfall des Shuttles entsteht. Gerade der Rücktransport aus dem Alp war eine der großen Leistungen des Space Shuttle. Und die Liste der Dinge, die die letzten zwei oder drei Space Shuttles von Bord der Raumstation mitbringen sollen, damit man hier unten entweder mehr lernt über die Ursachen von Fehlern dort oben oder einfach Proben wieder zur Erde zurückbekommt, die in vernünftiger Weise ausgewertet werden können. Die ist riesenlang und da gibt es einen hohen Druck und eine hohe Konkurrenz, diese Dinge noch aus der Raumstation nach Hause zu bringen. Danach ist für lange Zeit das einzig rückkehrfähige Gerät die Soyuz-Kapsel. Und genauso wenig, wie sie viel hochbringen kann, kann sie noch weniger runterbringen. Ich habe auf 50 Kilo vielleicht Nutzlass gesessen in meinem Flug. Da war also sicherlich immer eine ganz große Debatte, was muss runter, was brauchen wir unbedingt unten, was muss oben bleiben, weil dieser Rücktransport nicht zu gewährleisten ist. Und eine Landeraktion von der Soyuz ist im wahrsten Sinne eine Search-and-Rescue-Aktion. Also wirklich eine Rettungsaktion. Nicht, dass das Leben der Kosmonauten mit jeder Landung gefährdet ist. Aber man landet irgendwo in Kasachstan und die Suchtruppen müssen sich mühsam auf den Landerort einspiralieren. Und mitten auf einem Acker, oder wenn es gut geht, kann aber auch ein Sumpf sein, müssen dann diese Menschen und die Nutzlasten aus der Kapsel herausgeholt werden. Da ist keine Zeit für empfindliche Kristalle oder für irgendwas, was einen bestimmten garantierten Temperaturtransport braucht. Das ist äußerst schwierig zu gewährleisten. Es ist ein Riesendefizit, was wir für bestimmte Spachten von Untersuchungen in der nahen Zukunft identifiziert haben. Wenn wir da in Europa natürlich in die Lücke springen und sagen, unsere ATV ist nicht nur in der Lage, an die Raumstation heranzunavigieren, sondern es könnte in mehreren Stufen ausgebaut auch Sachen heile wieder zur Erde zu bringen. Nicht das ganze ATV sicherlich, aber entsprechende Zusätze im ATV. Da würden wir sicherlich eine große Lücke auch in der Raumstationslogistik schließen können. Ich sehe momentan noch nicht, dass das sehr viel Begeisterung entfacht, diese Idee, aber es ist ja noch nicht aller Tage Abend. Wenn man dann mal den Fall genügend schildert, mag es da eine Entwicklung geben, dass man ATV auch mit einer Rückkehrfunktion versieht.
Aber noch ist es nicht so weit. Vielleicht noch mal kurz zu dem, was es gibt. Also die ganzen Module, wie viele Leute sind gleichzeitig auf der Raumstation derzeit?
Die Standartbesetzung ist sechs Leute, die in zwei Strömen geführt werden. Einem A-Strom und einem B-Strom. Das heißt, diese Besatzungen gehen nicht alle gleichzeitig an Bord und gehen alle gleichzeitig weg, sondern sie überlappen sich mit 2, 4, 2, 4, 2, 4 Monatsrhythmus. Fangen wir mit der A-Besatzung an. Das ist typischerweise die Besatzung, die dann Aufgaben, vor allen Dingen der Robotik etc. an Bord der Raumstation mitbekommt, die immer aus Russen und Amerikanern bestehen. Das heißt, da fliegen keine Partner der Amerikaner mit.
Die Russen haben gar keine Partner sozusagen?
Nein, die Russen haben keine Partner. Die haben mal Touristen geflogen. Das war so eine Situation, wo einfach ein Sitz frei war.
Auch zur ISS?
Aus der Logistik heraus. Das ist aber in der momentanen Planung nicht mehr wirklich zur ISS.
Ach ja, ich dachte, das wäre nur in der mir gewesen.
Endlich bei der ISS dann auch. Diese Flüge der A-Linie gehen also für etablierende Besatzung. Zwei Monate später kommt dann die B-Linie. Das ist auch ein Soyuz-Flug. Und füllen die Besatzung auf sechs Leute damit auf. Das haben wir jetzt etabliert. Das ist jetzt eingespielt, dieses System. Da sind dann, neben dem russischen Piloten des Soyuz, sind dann auch durchaus neben den Amerikanern, Kanadier, Europäern und Japanern zu finden. Nach sechs Monaten nach Start der A-Linie geht die A-Linie vom Bord. Es kann entweder vorher eine neue Besatzung, A-Besatzung, schon an Bord sein. Dann haben wir kurzzeitig neun Leute. Meistens ist es aber so, dass erst ein paar Tage später, um die Raumstation nicht zu überlasten, ein paar Tage später die nächste A-Linie.
Also für kurze Zeit hält die ISS auch neun Leute aus?
Für kurze Zeit hält sie neun Leute aus. Vor allen Dingen für kurzzeitig müssen die drei Beler dann wurschteln, dass sie die Raumstation alleine betreiben. Die sind aber dann inzwischen schon so erfahren, dass das also keinen Gefährdungs- oder Einbruch in der Tätigkeit da oben bedeutet, bis dann die nächsten A-Leute kommen. Die treffen dann auf einen B-Kommandanten sozusagen, der dann das Kommando übernommen hat. Und arbeiten mit dem wieder zwei oder vier Monate, je nachdem, wie es geht. Und bevor sie dann selbst das Kommando übernehmen und die nächsten B-Leute erwarten. Das ist die Abfolge von Besatzungen garantiert, dass immer eine erfahrene Besatzung an Bord ist. Das Problem ist jetzt natürlich nur alle Funktionen, die an Bord wahrgenommen werden müssen, auch mit jeweils diesen Besatzungen zu treffen. Und das ist ein Gleichungssystem mit vielen Unbekannten und vielen Randbedingungen. Das Ganze wird zusammengefasst in einer Qualifikationsmatrix der jeweiligen Besatzungen. Es muss immer sicherlich ein Spezialist für jedes Modul dabei sein, falls Reparaturen auftauchen, dass der Spezialist trainiert ist, die Spezialistin trainiert ist, diese Arbeiten vorzunehmen. Das Ganze auf dem russischen Segment, das Ganze für Columbus-GEM und das amerikanische Segment. Da sind beliebige Gleichungen zu lösen, bevor es dann zu der Ernennung einer bestimmten Besatzung kommt. Und entsprechend werden diese Besatzungen dann auch im Training darauf hingeführt, was ihre Spezialaufgaben sind.
Wie läuft so das ab? Das Richtigste ist ja so ein Tagesablauf für die Astronauten extrem durchgeplant. Also total durchgeplant. Wie sieht so ein Tag aus?
Die Rahmenbedingungen sind genug Schlaf, zweimal am Tag eine Stunde Sport mindestens, um die Effekte der Schwerlosigkeit auf Knochenmuskeln, aber auch Kreislauf mindestens abzumildern. Man kann sie nicht ganz verhindern, aber abzumildern.
So wie kann man gar nicht trainieren?
Sodass man eine Rückkehrfähigkeit hat.
Kann man gar nicht so viel trainieren, um das zu kompensieren?
Nein, das ist einfach von der Mechanik her. Die Trainingsgeräte sind zwar schon ausgetüftelt, die man da oben hat, aber sie belasten einfach nicht alle diese Muskeln, die wir hier unten auf der Erde ganz normal durchgehen, laufen, stehen, sitzen, etc. Aber sie geben eine gute Auswahl und ein relativ stabiles Profil, damit er mit der Landung entsprechend zurechtkommt. Wenn ich immer das männliche Pronomen nutze.
Was ist denn mit diesem rotierenden Kreisbogen, den bei 2001 diese Raumstation hatte? Du hast ja gesagt, das wäre ja alles nicht so realistisch. Was ist das Problem? Warum gibt es denn das?
Das ist nicht realistisch, weil dieser Kreis, diese Zentrifugalkraft erst dann nicht übelkeitprovozierend wirkt, wenn man einen genügend großen Radius einführt. Das heißt, man muss schon eine große Struktur langsam rotieren lassen. Eine kleine Struktur schnell rotiert heißt, dass jede Seitenbewegung seitlich zur Drehrichtung sofort einem Übelkeit verursacht. Das liegt an der Verschaltung. An der Verschaltung unserer Bogengänge. Dass sie auf solche kontinuierlichen Drehbewegungen und dann Seitenbewegungen mit Außenmatrix-Elementen reagieren, nämlich die Übelkeit erzeugen.
Wie groß müsste denn das Rad sein, damit dieser Effekt nicht mehr so...
Ich hab's nicht durchgerechnet. Das geht ja dann graduell weg. Das ist wie so ein London-Eye, so ein Riesenrad. Wir gewöhnen uns ja auch an den Raumflug als provozierend, als übelkeitprovozierende Sache. Nach ein, zwei Tagen ist das bei den meisten, oder ein Großteil ist das dann weg. Manche haben gar keinen Effekt, aber diese Seidbewegungen in einem rotierenden System sind immer sehr provozierend. Die Coriolis-Kräfte und ähnliches, was dann wirkt. Das haben sie in Russland auch schon mal mit Experimenten belegt. In einem Raum, der auf einer großen Drehscheibe montiert war, bewegten und lebten mal ein paar Leute. Und sollten dann auch gezielt Kopfbewegungen machen. Das hat das nur unterstrichen, dass das sehr provozierend ist. Das heißt, die Zentrifugalkraft ersetzt die Schwerkraft nur in eine Richtung, hat aber in anderen Richtungen unangenehme Nebenwirkungen, wenn es nicht ein großes Element ist. Zweitens wollen wir überhaupt keine künstliche Schwere auf der Raumstation, weil wir wollen ja Schwerelosigkeit erforschen.
Na gut, aber zumindest in diesem Ring wäre es ja dann für die Astronauten doch eher eine Wohltat.
Ja, braucht aber nicht. Ich meine, die Astronauten, die hochfliegen, sollen sich darauf einrichten, Schwerelosigkeit-Experimente an der Raumstation zu machen und nicht entspannt auf einer Couch zu liegen, unangeschnallt und ein Buch zu lesen.
Na ja gut, man kann es ja mal durchsprechen. So sieht auf jeden Fall sehr schön aus.
Es sieht schön aus. Für eine Mars-Mission mag das auch das Gegebene sein, dass man was für sich, den Reaktor an einem langen Saal irgendwo hat und das Lebe-Modul an einem anderen Ende des Saals. Dann induziert man diese Schwerkraft. Das sind ja alles sehr schöne, fiktionale Konzepte. Für die ISS sollte es eine Zentrifuge geben, gar nicht mal eine Humanzentrifuge, sondern eine, die Referenzexperimente, biologische und sonstiger Art, ständig unter 1G, simulierten 1G-Bedingungen hält. Die hat man abgesagt, weil es einfach viel zu viel Vibration, zu viel dynamische Störungen in die Raumstation setzt, eine solche Zentrifuge zu betreiben.
Das wäre dann sozusagen das zweite Problem dieses Rades, dass es einfach noch mal eine permanente Kreiselbewegung gibt, die man dann ja auch noch mit in alles einberechnen müsste, die dem eigentlichen Ziel der Stabilität im Raum entgegenwirkt. Zurück zu dem Tagesablauf. Also klar, Sport muss getrieben werden, weil den Kreisel gibt es nicht, der schon mit der Klappe funktioniert.
Mahlzeiten, wenn geht, natürlich zusammen planen, dass die Besatzung auch Gelegenheit hat, an bestimmten Stellen des Tages zusammenzukommen und sich auszutauschen. Vorschlaf- und Nachschlafphasen frei halten für persönliche Hygiene, für meinen Computer gucken, E-Mail, was weiß ich, aber auch schon vorbereiten das nächste Tages. Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Geschäft, abends schon mal zu schauen, in welche Fallen man am nächsten Tag tappen kann.
Hat man denn da Internet?
Ein, sagen wir mal, gesichertes Internet. Also ich glaube, das geht mit Desktop-Funktion, dass man also über den Stationsrechner, einen Rechner unten auf der Erde, desktopmäßig ansteuert. Und der Stationsrechner selbst war nicht im Internet verbunden. Wenn es da Viren gibt, dass es da nicht auf die Station durchhaut. Und auch nur dann, wenn eben der TDRS, also die Satellitenstrecke zugeschaltet ist, mit der Sprechfunkverbindung, macht man das nicht. Man kann auch telefonieren. Das geht auf die gleiche Art, Internet-Phone, IP-Phone. Bei Breitbandier-Datenverbindung kann man sich über ein Relais in das Welttelefonnetz einwählen.
Und alles kostenlos?
Zum Kosten zahlt der Staat. Der Tagesablauf. Die Zeit ist da oben künstlich gesetzt. Weil wir Kontrollzentren in Moskau, Houston, in Japan und Europa haben, haben wir da oben glücklicherweise GMT gewählt, das heißt Greenwich Mean Time. Die ändert sich auch nicht in Winterzeit und Sommerzeit. Ist für uns momentan ja eine Stunde vor.
Die Tage sind ja eh kürzer. Da muss man sich auch noch mit Sommerzeit nachhelfen.
Aber auch die Schichten im Kontrollzentrum ändern sich. Also dann nicht die Arbeiten nach diesen Stationszeiten. 6 Uhr GMT wecken. Dann erstmal eine Phase, wo die mit Sicht beschäftigt sind und Vorbereitung ihrer Aufgaben, Hygiene und ähnlichen Kaffee kochen. Etwa 2 Stunden später gibt es die erste DPC. Also um 8 Uhr gibt es die Daily Planning Conference. Da sind alle Kontrollzentren und alle Besatzungsmitglieder zusammengeschaltet, gehen durch den Tag durch, klären noch Fragen. Updates, die über die Nacht in die Computer geladen wurden, werden der Besatzung dann erklärt. Dann gehen die an ihr Tagewerk. So etwa 12, 1 Uhr treffen sich alle wieder zum Lunch. Wer Zeit hat, natürlich.
Also sie schlafen auch alle zum gleichen Zeitpunkt?
Ja, haben dann alle Sport gemacht. Auch schon mal die erste Runde. Das ist ja eine Logistik, die auch auf den Sportgeräten geplant werden muss, wer wann Zeit hat. Nach dem Essen dann weiter entlang einer Timeline, die für jedes Besatzungsmitglied im 5 Minuten, 15 Minuten Abstand vorschreibt, was zu tun ist, welche Prozedur, welche Bureausanleitung zu benutzen ist. Die Kontrollzentren warten auch darauf, dass das jetzt so stattfindet, damit sie das unterstützen können, damit sie die Zigarette einschalten, ausschalten, unterstützen können. Das ist also eine sehr, sehr enge Choreografie, die mit vielen Iterationsschritten bis zu dem Tag dann verfeinert wurde. Und dann wird dieser Plan von allen gemeinsam abgearbeitet. Bis zum Abend, 6 Uhr oder was, gibt es dann, also 18 Uhr gibt es das Abendessen, wo wir auch die Besatzung wieder allein lassen, vorher noch eine DPC, eine Abend-DPC, wo nochmal der Tag dann wie Andreas Brehm gesagt hat, Paroli laufen gelassen wird. Und das schließt dann den formellen Tag ab. Also ab da hält sich das Kontrollzentrum dann auch zurück mit Anrufen und könnte man mal da gucken und da ist uns noch was eingefallen und so weiter, um eben auch die Besatzung nicht jetzt permanent unter...
Aber tagsüber ist das schon durchaus auch eine interaktive Geschichte.
Tagsüber ist es gemeint interaktiv. Das Kontrollzentrum, die entsprechende Spezialisten an der Konsole hat, die dann dem Astronauten über die Schulter gucken. Wir haben auch viel Video und sagen...
Das heißt, die Einsatzpläne für die Astronauten sind schon koordiniert, aber trotzdem wird die für jedes Modul separat gesteuert. Das heißt, hier im Columbus-Zentrum hier in Oberpfaffenhofen kümmert man sich eigentlich nur um diejenigen, die jetzt mit dem Columbus... Ein oder zwei Leute?
Bis zu vier Leute sein, je nachdem, wieviel da trainiert sind an diesem Columbus-Modul. Also uns ist es egal, ob es ein ESA-Astronaut ist oder ein Japaner, ein Kanadier, ein US-Astronaut, die Russen haben wenig am Columbus zu tun. Die Aufgabenverteilung geht rein nach Training und jetzt ist es dran, also macht es der, der dafür ausgebildet ist. Und die unterstützen wir.
Das heißt, ein Astronaut, der vor Ort ist, ist auch in der Regel in mehreren Modulen zu Gange, eben alles, wofür er trainiert ist, aber er ist in der Regel nicht nur für eins trainiert, sondern eben für mindestens ein paar. Für ein Segment, für ein amerikanischer oder russischer. Ich hab jetzt beim Besuch im Kontrollzentrum gesehen, es gibt da oben, wie man sich das immer so schön vorstellt, viele große Bildschirme, auf denen allerlei interessantes Zeug abläuft, unter anderem auch dieser Astronautenzeitplan. Da sind dann alle Astronauten geführt, die in irgendeiner Form mit dem Columbus was zu tun haben. Und die anderen eigentlich nicht. Nein, nein, nein.
Der Zeitplan ist global. Russische Segment, amerikanische Segment, Destiny, Kibo, das ist das japanische Modul und Columbus. Inklusive aller Systemarbeiten, vielleicht Robotik draußen oder Ankoppeln, Abkoppeln von irgendwelchen Sachen. Das ist alles auf diesem Zeitplan vorhanden, sonst wird es nicht aufgehen, wenn jeder so sein eigenes betreibt. Und wir kümmern uns aber vom Columbus-Kontrollzentrum, kümmern uns nur darum, dass im Columbus die Geräte und die Voraussetzungen geschaffen werden, damit dann das Besatzungsmitglied entsprechend die Arbeit ausstellt. Wir machen auch automatische Sachen, wo die Besatzung überhaupt nichts vermerkt. Also eine Zentrifugie im Biolabor an- und ausschalten oder eine Videoaufnahme von irgendeiner Flüssigkeit, die im FSL, im Fluid Science Lab behandelt wird. Das merkt die Besatzung gar nicht. Aber alles konzentriert sich natürlich auf die Interaktion mit der Besatzung, weil das ist der humane Faktor dieser Timeline. Dann kommen wir zur Vorruhephase, wo also nochmal alles aufgearbeitet wird. Anschließend dann 6 bis 8 Stunden Schlaf. Je nachdem, also garantierte Schlafphase von 8 Stunden.
Dann gibt es Freizeit.
Das ist Freizeit, wobei man aber auch voraussetzt, dass die jetzt nicht je nachdurch machen am nächsten Tag mit Augen rinden, dass irgendwelche wichtigen Experimenten erscheinen, sondern schon Vernunft planen lassen. Samstag ist ein halber Tag frei. Da dürfen wir nur zwei Stunden. Da dürfen wir nur einen halben Tag planen. Und sonntags ist ganz frei. Da dürfen wir bis zwei Stunden irgendwelche ganz wichtigen Sachen noch von der Crew machen lassen.
Wie wichtig sind denn diese Ruhe? Pausen da oben?
Das kann keiner in dem Stil wie in der Space Lab Mission, wie wir damals gemacht haben, 6 Monate durcharbeiten. Das ist schon sehr wichtig. Diese Ruhephasen sind ja auch nicht aus dem Fenster gucken, sondern da ist eine Menge Kommunikation inzwischen dazugekommen durch die Kommunikationswege, die sich eröffnet haben. Aber im Wesentlichen ist es eigentlich das Verdauen auch dessen, was man darüber gemacht hat, noch mal Notizen nachschauen, vielleicht noch das eine oder andere in Ordnung bringen und sich was einfallen lassen, wie man das Problem am nächsten Tag umschifft. Also man ist nie so ganz außer Dienst. Die Momente, wo man, ich glaube nicht, dass man da mit sechs Leuten vorm Video hängt und Chips futtert und lauwarmes Wasser trinkt und sich da völlig abkoppelt. Man ist immer in einer unnatürlichen Umgebung. Man weiß um die Bedeutung dieses Raumfluges. Man weiß, wie kostbar die Zeit da buchstäblich bezahlt ist, die man da oben hat. Also der Gedanke an Schlafen war bei mir schon fremd. Ich dachte, wie kannst du die Zeit da oben überhaupt schlafen? Das ist ja heute zur Zeit. Ich habe allerdings die Erfahrung gemacht, dass man am Ende eines solchen Tages nicht physisch erschöpft ist, sondern psychisch. Dass man einfach durch die Konzentration, durch die Verantwortung, durch das Funktionieren müssen, so ausgebrannt ist, dass man automatisch in Schlaf fällt. Ich hätte es nicht geglaubt, aber es ist so wahr.
Wie schwierig ist es denn überhaupt, seine psychische Verfassung so auf dem Damm zu halten? Ich meine, gegen die Muskelrückbildung gibt es den Sporttrainer und da läuft man. Aber das sind ja einfach normale Vorgänge. Wie hält man sich da mental am Leben? Weil ich meine, am Ende des Tages merkt man, man ist irgendwie dann doch mal so 300, 400 Kilometer von der Erde entfernt und zwar in eine Richtung, wo die anderen alle nicht sind. Und es ist so eine absurde Situation irgendwie auch. Ist es immer so einfach da, den Kopf oben zu halten?
Also, wenn man es nicht mitbringt, kann man es am Bord nicht mehr lernen. Die Idee, da könnte man sehr ausgeprägte individuelle Neigungen runter schlucken und das wird man schon schaffen. Für sechs Monate kriegt man das schon geregelt. Hat sich gezeigt, das geht nicht. Was wir also schon vom Start weg machen, ist ein Select-In. Wir suchen Typen, die mit dieser Situation nachgewiesenerweise oder vermutlich mit mehreren hohen Wahrscheinlichkeiten zurechtkommen. Klassischerweise Leute, die in Forschungscamps in den entlegenen Gegenden der Welt unter Gefahr oder Hüsal schon mit guter Reputation was gemacht haben. Oder Leute, die sich auch in den Tests als Teamplayer erweisen, aber auch mal eine Entscheidung treffen und durchführen können, die vielleicht das Team aus einer schwierigen Lage dann ausgeführt hat.
Also wer jetzt ein halbes Jahr an Antarktis aushält, der schafft es auch im Orbit.
Eine gute Kandidatin, wir sollten nie die Damen vergessen.
Ja, das ist aber trotzdem ein Männer dominierter Beruf, oder?
Ja, das muss aber nicht so sein. Die Amerikaner tun Lobenswertes, indem sie die Quote der Frauen schon sehr hoch gesetzt haben. Die Russen haben aus mehr unbekannten Gründen nur einige Kosmonautinnen ausgebildet und hochgeschickt. Wir versuchen unser Bestes, aber das Angebot in technischen Berufen ist natürlich sehr Männer dominiert. So kommt das in der Statistik dann auch leider durch. Völlig unverständlicherweise, weil die Aufgabe da oben ist nicht geschlechtsspezifisch. Im Gegenteil würde ich sagen, dass eine gemischte Crew besser funktioniert als eine all-male.
Auch aus solchen psychologischen Erwägungen.
Wir haben also das Prinzip des Select-In. Wir wollen schon die richtigen Typen rekrutieren und nicht erst in der Ausbildung sagen, das darfst du aber nicht oder das ist aber jetzt ungeschickt. Dazu dient natürlich auch die Phase, wo die erstmal durch die Welt geschickt werden und sich in vielen Kulturen und mit vielen Technikkulturen vertraut machen müssen. Nicht zuletzt der Erwerb einer fremden Sprache. Russisch ist da sicherlich Pflicht, aber das Englische bringen die meisten ja mit. Diese Erfahrung macht sich dann am Bord auch bewährt, dass die persönlichen Dinge sehr hinten angestellt werden und man gemeinsam an dieser Aufgabe arbeitet und natürlich auch sechs Monate aushalten muss. Das kann man nicht, wenn man nicht schläft oder nicht...
Aber trotzdem wird es doch Momente geben, wo man dann auch mit all seiner Routine und Abgebrüthheit einfach auch mal durchhängt, oder?
Das merkt man auch hier unten auf der Erde. Wir können es merken, indem die schnippischen Bemerkungen über Funk zunehmen. Niemand würde über Funk einen Tiraden da loslassen. Das ist der Funk-Code sozusagen, das Codex, dass man das nicht tut. Aber wir merken, das habe ich doch jetzt schon dreimal gefragt. Das sind dann schon so typische Andeutungen. Moment mal, ich bin mit eurer Arbeit da unten oder der Zuarbeit nicht zufrieden. Ihr lasst mich hier hängen. Typischerweise schließen sich die Mannschaften zusammen und denken, also es ist nicht, dass einer an Funk kommt und sagt, der und der hat das wohl wieder verbockt und jetzt muss ich das ausbügeln. Ich möchte überhaupt nicht darauf eingehen. Die Psychologie eines Dschungelcamps ist also sicherlich nicht unsere Erfolgsstrategie. Das ganz bestimmt nicht. Das liegt ein bisschen auch an den Kontrollzentren, das zu merken, dass die Videobesatzung da ein bisschen anders möchte, die Sachen anders und unfertig serviert haben, darauf einzugehen. Es kommt dann zu einer Solidarisierung der Leute an Bord. Sex ist ja schon eine Menge. Da wird man sicherlich nicht homogen von einer Besatzung ausgehen.
Und sie sitzen ja, wie man so schön sagt, alle im gleichen Boot.
Und wenn nichts hilft, muss man auch eine Hierarchisierung einführen. Speziell in Krisensituationen ist natürlich die Existenz einer gefesten Hierarchie an Bord absolut notwendig. Das kann ich aus eigener Erfahrung und meinem Brandfall da sagen, dass das überhaupt keine Widersprüche zuließt. Wenn jetzt jeder gesagt hätte, ich meine, wir sollten dahin oder dort hin oder was weiß ich, jeder hat dazu beigetragen, eine Meinungsbildung zu erreichen. Aber die Entscheidung hat der vorher nominierte Kommandant dann getroffen. Deshalb ist diese Kommandostruktur in diesem Fall natürlich auch installiert und wichtig an Bord der Raumstation. Ansonsten ist es aber sicherlich ein sehr partnerschaftliches Beitragen der einzelnen Besatzungsmitglieder, die Situation nicht anbrennen zu lassen. Wir gehen dagegen vom Kontrollzentrum, indem wir einfach versuchen, besser zu arbeiten oder besser die Wünsche der Mannschaft zu treffen. Es gibt ja sehr viele Privatgespräche auch mit den Managern oder mit dem Crew Flight Surgeon, also nennt sich das der Crew Doctor, wo man da auch Zuspruch und Korrektur anbringen kann. Am besten ist es immer, wenn eine große Aufgabe vorsteht. Ein Raumfahrzeug kommt an, muss angekoppelt werden, entladen werden, eine EVA, also einen Außeneinsatz, im Raumanzug steht an, der braucht sehr viel Vorbereitungszeit und die Mannschaftsmitglieder, die das machen, müssen also bestens unterstützt werden. Und da gibt es also eine Reihe von Highlights über die 6-Monats-Missionsdauer verteilt, die in der Lage ist, eine Besatzung dann auch wirklich bei der Stange zu halten. Nehmen wir jetzt mal das Beispiel des Mars-Fluges. Wenn das Highlight-Mars-Landung vorbei ist, trifft man da natürlich auch eine ganz andere Gefahr. Nämlich, dass die Rückreise so öde wird und die Erwartungen an die Erde so groß, dass man da auch mit der Grubsüche sehr vorsichtig sein sollte.
Weil einfach keine großen Ereignisse mehr anstehen.
Das ist an Bord der Raumstation nicht. Man fühlt sich doch noch eher nah. Und auch die Verbindungen, gerade mit Telefon oder mal eine Videocon oder Ähnliches sind eigentlich vielfältig. Sodass man, glaube ich, die sechs Monate ganz gut kalkuliert hat als das, was man an Effektivität gut von der Crew erwarten kann.
Alles sehr interessant, alles sehr spannend. Trotzdem, denke ich, müssen wir langsam mal zum Ende kommen. Was mich trotzdem noch interessiert, ist so ein bisschen die denkbare Zukunft von Raumstationen. Auch die ISS ist nur auf begrenzte Zeit geplant. Ich glaube, so nominell ist es 2020.
Wir arbeiten gerade dran, das Zertifikat auf 2020 zu erwarten.
Wobei das ist auch alles nur vorläufig durchaus vorstellbar, dass auch die ISS noch länger lebt, oder?
Ja, da gibt es auch schon Interesse, dass vielleicht dann in Weltraumhotel oder in historische Zeit umzuwandeln, je nachdem, wie die Transportsituation zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist, ob sich das aus dem Suborbital, das kommerzielle aus dem Suborbital, schon ins Orbital erstreckt. Es ist natürlich immer ein, erst mal vom Steuerzahler bezahltes Objekt. Das sollte jetzt nicht der privaten Nutzung oder der kommerziell privaten Nutzung...
Aber ich meine, verbraucht sich die ISS oder gibt es irgendwann diesen Bedarf nicht mehr?
Es gibt sicherlich einen Verbrauch. Wir werden auch vielleicht Funktionen sehen, die dann nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen.
Aber es ist doch modular.
Man könnte doch im Prinzip alles austauschen, oder? Der Aufwand, den man jetzt für den Bau dieser Module und den Start betrieben hat, der ist sicherlich erst mal abschreckend, da jetzt eine Serienfertigung aufzulegen. Ich kann mir denken, dass Kupola die Fenster verkratzen, blind werden, dann ist natürlich die Attraktivität da auch ein bisschen raus. Aber es gibt ja Leute, die an Urlaub gerne in solchen historischen Zeiten verbringen. Das mag durchaus eine Nutzung sein, die man nach 2020, wenn die Forschung nicht mehr so brennend interessiert ist, wenn auch die am Bord verwendeten Sachen einfach veraltet sind und die Forschung da drüben weggegangen ist und nichts Neues mehr so aufgebracht werden kann, dass man dann an eine ganz andere Nutzung denkt. Über die Raumstation hinaus denken wir natürlich in Richtung, was kann die Raumstation beitragen, uns effektiver, billiger, schneller auf irgendwelche weiteren in den Raum rausgehenden Missionen zu bringen. Ich rede mal gar nicht von Modoberfläche oder Marsoberfläche, aber ich kann mir denken, dass gerade die Frage einer effektiven Gesunderhaltung der Kosmonauten, der Astronauten an Bord der Raumstation am besten erforscht werden kann. Das ist jetzt nicht primär Forschungsziel für meine Begriffe, aber ist einfach etwas, was wir dadurch lernen, dass wir die bestehenden Methoden weiterentwickeln. Wir können sehr viel über Lebenserhaltungssysteme lernen. Die Raumstation über Langzeitbeobachtung der Lebenserhaltungssysteme der Raumstation. Da kriegen wir also Aufschlüsse, was ist ein Minimumstandacht, um auch regenerative oder in sich geschlossene Kreisläufe zu unterhalten. Wir lernen eine Menge über die Erde auch. Und unseren Riesenkreislauf hier, der aber auch natürlich nicht endlos ausgedehnt ist. Wir können eine Menge auch lernen über Ingenieur, Lösungen für Probleme wie die Struktur von großen Orbitalkomplexen, wie das Beherrschen eben auch von Verkehr in und um die Raumstation herum. Also das sind alles Dinge, die natürlich den Schritt zur nächsten Mission kleiner machen. Nicht unbedingt dann zwingend die nächste Mission vorgeben, aber zumindest diese Erfahrungen dann in die Berechnung in der neuen Mission einbringen. Und da hat dann jeder so seine Lieblingsmission. Die einen wollen zurück zum Mond, weil sie denken, das ist vor der Haustür und allmählich wäre es mal wieder fällig. Und 50 Jahre Mondlandung, dann müssten wir also, wir schaffen es nicht zum Mars, dann müssen wir jetzt zum Mond zurück. Die Frage, ob das natürlich viel bringt, mein Favorit ist ehrlich gesagt eine Mission, die eher Himmelskörper anfliegt, die in ähnlicher Weise wie Mond oder Mars auch Lösungen für Fragen bietet, wie zum Beispiel Asteroiden oder ähnliches. Da kann man auch sehr viel mehr Techniken erproben, die man braucht, um tiefer in den Weltraum vorzustoßen, als wieder ein Mondlandungsszenario zu entwickeln. Wir werden immer schlauer auch, wie bei Roboter, für wissenschaftliche Vorhaben einsetzen. Die Rover auf Mars, das ist natürlich ein bisschen beschränkend, wenn wir da immer nur mit 25 Minuten Abstand kommandieren und Daten empfangen können. Also fliegen wir mal hin, setzen uns in Mars orbit und machen das online sozusagen und holen das Maximum aus diesen Robotern raus. Und vielleicht irgendwann landen wir auch. Das ist natürlich das Spektakuläre. Das ist natürlich das, was die Aufwendungen dann letztlich auch in der öffentlichen Meinung spektakulär rechtfertigt. Aber ich glaube, wir sind ruhiger geworden. Es ist nicht mehr die Frage, muss das in diesem Jahrzehnt passieren, sondern es wird schon passieren. Und hoffentlich sind wir dabei, wenn es passiert. Bis dahin arbeiten wir aber beständig an diesen Fragen. Und Raumstation ist unsere beste Chance, das zu tun. Wir haben nichts anderes.
Musste denn eine Raumstation zwingend im Erdorbit sein? Ließen sich nicht Raumstationen auch weiter im All bringen, wo sie jetzt auch solche Probleme wie permanente Anziehung der Erde und die doch noch spürbare Nähe der Atmosphäre da ist?
Das skaliert sich mit der Fähigkeit unserer Antriebe, tiefer in den Raum vorzustoßen. Die momentane Flugbehöhe der Raumstation ist einfach ein Kompromiss zwischen noch erdnah genug, um vielleicht noch Einflüsse von Atmosphäre und anderen Effekten zu merken, sodass wir dauernd das Orbit der Raumstation korrigieren müssten. Wenn wir auf 1000 km gingen, hätten wir praktisch keine Orbit-Korrektur, aber wir könnten mit dem Shuttle nicht hinfliegen oder nur noch mit einem Pfefferminz-Plätzchen als Nutzlast.
Weil man einfach mehr Energie bräuchte für die Startstaffel?
Ja, weil man einfach schlieh weiter raus, dass du Energie hast. Das sind einfach dann Bestrechnungen, die man ausführt, wo setzt man die Raumstation hin. Genauso wie sich die Russen dann auch das Orbit überlegt haben. Die internationale Raumstation folgt der Myr- und Sajut- und Almaz-Tradition in 51,8 Grad. Es gibt kein ehrenes Gesetz, dass das so sein muss. Aber das ist genau das Orbit, was die beliebten Landstriche unserer Welt am besten unter sich abdeckt. Man kann auch immer im polaren Orbit fliegen, aber es ist einfach für die Dinge, die man tun will, vielleicht nicht so effektiv.
Und wäre so eine vollautomatisierte, menschenfreie Raumstation auch vorstellbar?
MZ6 kann ich da nur sagen. Das ist die Station, die Traflichtbrüche weiterleitete. Bei Orion, Raumpatrouille Orion. Mit so einer schnarrenden Roboterstimme.
Und, war das realistisch genug?
Nein, das war zukunftsweisend, sagen wir mal, aber nicht realistisch. Was soll eine automatische Raumstation? Erstmal müssen wir lernen, die Sachen, die wir auf planetare Oberflächen bringen, Mond, Mars, Asteroiden, weiterzunutzen. Also nicht mit der nächsten Landesstelle komplett neu die Infrastruktur da hochzuziehen. Das wäre dann so ein Kern einer automatischen Station, dass wir zumindest mal zwei Module aufeinander bewegen können und verbinden. Oder mit dem Rover irgendwas machen, wo schon eine Landesstufe steht und irgendwelche Ressourcen vorhält. Bis zur Treibstoffgenerierung auf dieser Oberfläche. Alles spannende Sachen, die uns schrittlichenweise dann auch weiter rausbringen. Nur, wenn wir natürlich da Menschen hinterher schicken wollen, wollen wir auch sichergehen, dass diese Stationen funktionieren. Da wird immer noch ein Netz und doppelten Boden wahrscheinlich dann einzuziehen sein. Deshalb ist das so aufwendig. Deshalb ist Mars eine ganz andere Kiste als die Raumstationen, die wir jetzt haben, wo wir praktisch aus dem Orbit fallen, wenn irgendwas los ist und in zwei Stunden zurück sein können. Nicht unter bequemen Umständen und wahrscheinlich irgendwo in einer kanadischen Taiga. Und dann wacht man erst noch eine Weile, bis die Helikopter kommen. Aber immerhin, das ist die Möglichkeit. Vom Mod war es mit Apollo 13 schon dramatischer. Die haben aber noch so eine Rückkehrbahn gehabt. Bei Mars ist es ausgeschlossen und erfordert also Redundanz und Triple-Redundanz und eine garantierte Möglichkeit, trotz aller Fehlversagen, zurückzukommen.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, weil jetzt noch etwas ganz Wichtiges auf der Seele brennt, was wir noch unterbringen sollten.
Das war jetzt natürlich Reinholds Blick der Zukunft der Raumfahrt.
Naja, das ist ja auch kein uninformierter Blick.
Meine berufliche Perspektive wird nicht weit über die Raumstation hinausgehen. Meine Lebensperspektive, da haben wir natürlich alle unsere Hoffnung, dass wir unseren Enkeln auch mal eine Landung irgendwo oder einen Großstart im All zeigen können.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, schauen wir uns jetzt mal die Docking-Sequenz von dem ATV an und gucken, wie es mit der ISS jetzt heute ganz konkret weitergeht. Und ich sage erst mal vielen Dank.
Gern geschehen, auf Wiederzeit wieder.
Und das war es, die zehnte Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Und es bleibt nicht die letzte. Hier geht es bald weiter, auch mit vielen Themen, die wir hier kurz angeschnitten haben, die hier Platz finden werden noch im Programm. Bis dahin sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.